If you want more from the show, join The Rest Is History Club. And with Christmas coming, you can also gift a whole year of access to the history lover in your life. Just head to the rest is history.com and click Gifts. Get you and your crew to the big shows with Go Transit. Go connects to all the main concert venues like TD Coliseum in Hamilton and Scotia Bank Arena in Toronto. And Go makes it affordable with special e-ticket fairs. A one-day weekend pass offers unlimited travel across the network. work on any weekend day or holiday for just $10.
如果您想了解更多节目内容，请加入“历史即是如此”俱乐部（The Rest Is History Club）。随着圣诞节临近，您还可以为您生命中热爱历史的人赠送一整年的会员资格。只需前往 therestishistory.com 并点击“礼物”（Gifts）即可。乘坐 Go Transit 交通工具，带上您的伙伴去参加大型演出吧。Go 交通网连接着多伦多的 TD 体育馆（TD Coliseum）和丰业银行体育馆（Scotiabank Arena）等主要音乐会场馆。Go 交通还通过特别的电子票价让出行变得经济实惠。周末一日通票仅需 10 美元，即可在任何周末或节假日无限次乘坐整个交通网络。
And a weekday group pass offers the same weekday travel flexibility from $30 for two people and up to $60 for $5. Buy yours at go-transit.com slash tickets. Canada's Wonderland is bringing the holiday magic this season with Winterfest on select nights now through January 3rd. Step into a winter wonderland filled with millions of dazzling lights, festive shows, rides, and holiday treats. Plus, Coca-Cola is back.
而工作日团体通票提供同样的工作日出行灵活性，两人票价 30 美元起，五人票价最高 60 美元。请在 go-transit.com/tickets 购买您的车票。加拿大仙境乐园（Canada's Wonderland）本季通过“冬季庆典”（Winterfest）带来节日魔法，即日起至 1 月 3 日的特定夜晚开放。步入一个充满数百万璀璨灯光、节日表演、游乐设施和节日美食的冬季仙境。此外，可口可乐公司也回归了。
with Canada's kindness community, celebrating acts of kindness nationwide, with a chance at $100,000 donation for the winning community and a 2026 holiday caravan stop. Learn more at canadaswunderland.com. Reason number 59 why Nissan is built for our winter. Because when winter storms make on-road feel like off-road, we've got you.
携手加拿大的“善意社区”，在全国范围内庆祝善举，获胜社区将有机会获得 10 万美元捐款，并成为 2026 年节日大篷车的一站。详情请访问 canadaswunderland.com。日产（Nissan）为我们的冬季而打造的第 59 个理由：因为当冬季风暴让公路变得像越野路面时，我们为您保驾护航。
Road comes standard with intelligent all-wheel drive and remote engines start to conquer even the harshest winter conditions. Now lease a 2026 Roguess for 0.9% for 36 months or get $4,000 cash purchase bonus on remaining 2025 models. Visit your local Nissan dealer today or Nissan.C for more details. Conditions apply. This episode is sponsored by Hive. Britain revolutionized the future with the might of industrial power.
Rogue 车型标配智能全轮驱动和远程引擎启动功能，足以征服最严酷的冬季条件。现在租赁 2026 款 Rogue 可享 36 个月 0.9% 的利率，或在购买 2025 款剩余车型时获得 4,000 美元的现金购车奖励。立即访问您当地的日产经销商或访问 Nissan.ca 了解更多详情。受相关条件限制。本集由 Hive 赞助。英国曾以工业力量的强大威力彻底改变了未来。
But now you can transform your own energy future and take control with the power of Hive. Hive makes the most of the sun, with solar panels turning sunlight into greener electricity and enabling you to sell excess back to the grid. And Hive's thermostats make it possible for you to heat your home without lifting anything more than a thumb and an impressed brow. Their heat pumps draw warmth from the air
但现在，您可以利用 Hive 的力量改变自己的能源未来并掌握主动权。Hive 最大限度地利用太阳能，通过太阳能电池板将阳光转化为更环保的电力，并使您能够将多余的电力卖回电网。Hive 的恒温器让您无需动弹，只需动动手指、挑挑眉毛，就能调节家中的供暖。他们的热泵从空气中汲取热量，
and they keep it exactly where you want it. No smoke, no waste. Hive's EV Charger lets your car charge quietly overnight, recharging while you do too. Hive brings it all together, heating, charging and solar, managed from one simple app in a quiet revolution. In the long history of power, Hive helps you finally know yours. Head to hivehome.com to find out more, subject to survey and suitability. Hive app compatible with selected technology. Paid for surplus requires SEG tariff.
并将热量保持在您想要的精确位置。没有烟雾，没有浪费。Hive 的电动汽车充电器让您的爱车可以在夜间安静充电，在您休息时同步补能。Hive 将供暖、充电和太阳能融为一体，通过一个简单的应用程序进行管理，实现了一场安静的革命。在漫长的能源史上，Hive 帮助您最终掌握属于自己的力量。前往 hivehome.com 了解更多信息，需视勘测和适用性而定。Hive 应用程序兼容特定技术。支付盈余电量需符合 SEG 关税标准。
London lies today under the spell of a great terror. A nameless reprobate, half beast, half man is at large, who is daily gratifying, his murderous instincts on the most miserable and defenceless classes of the community. There can be no shadow of a doubt now that our original theory was correct, and that the White Chapel murderer who has now four, if not five, victims to his knife, is one man, and that man, a murderous maniac. Hidious malice, deadly cunning, insatiable thirst for blood. All these are the marks of the mad homicide.
伦敦今天笼罩在巨大的恐怖之中。一个无名的恶棍，半兽半人，正逍遥法外，他每天都在社会中最悲惨、最无助的阶层身上满足他那杀人的本能。现在毫无疑问，我们最初的理论是正确的，那个白教堂杀手——他现在刀下已有四名，甚至可能是五名受害者——是一个人，而且是一个杀人狂。令人毛骨悚然的恶意、致命的狡诈、对鲜血的贪婪渴求，这些都是疯狂杀人犯的特征。
The ghoul-like creature who stalks through the streets of London, stalking down his victim like a porny Indian, is simply drunk with blood, and he will have more. The question is, what are the people of London to do? The police have not even a clue. They are in despair at their utter failure to get so much as a scent of the criminal. London must rouse itself. No woman is safe while this ghoul is abroad. Up citizens then and do your own police work. So that was the evening star on Saturday the 8th of September 1888 after the discovery of
这个像食尸鬼一样的生物在伦敦街头徘徊，像印第安人追踪猎物一样追踪他的受害者，他简直是嗜血成性，而且他还会继续作案。问题是，伦敦人民该怎么办？警方甚至毫无头绪。他们对彻底失败、连罪犯的一点线索都抓不到感到绝望。伦敦必须觉醒。只要这个食尸鬼在外面，没有哪个女人是安全的。公民们，站起来，做你们自己的警察工作吧。那么，这就是 1888 年 9 月 8 日星期六的《晚星报》（Evening Star），在发现
yet another victim of the Whitechapel murderer, and I use the phrase Whitechapel murderer advisedly because he is not yet known as Jack the Ripper, although Dominic today we will be exploring how the Whitechapel murderer comes to get that appellation. We will indeed, yes. So let's remind people where and when we are. We are in the late summer of 1888. We are in the east end of London, which we describe, last time is this kind of labyrinth, this warren of crowded, narrow streets and sort of reeking tenement slums. And it's a national byword, the East End for poverty, for homelessness, for prostitution and for crime. And one of the things that's going to become very important
白教堂杀手的又一名受害者之后。我谨慎地使用了“白教堂杀手”这个词，因为他当时还不被称为“开膛手杰克”，尽管多米尼克，今天我们将探讨白教堂杀手是如何获得这个称号的。我们确实会探讨，是的。那么让我们提醒大家我们身处何时何地。我们是在 1888 年的夏末。我们是在伦敦东区，我们上次将其描述为一种迷宫，一个拥挤、狭窄的街道和散发着恶臭的廉租公寓贫民窟。东区是贫困、无家可归、卖淫和犯罪的代名词。而有一件事将变得非常重要，
in the next couple of episodes, it's an area that is being transformed by immigration, specifically Jewish refugees from the pogroms in Russia and in Poland. So to really, to really, To recap the story of the last episode, Tom, you described how on the 7th of August, a woman called Martha Tabram was found murdered in a tenement building off Whitechaple High Street, and her body had been stabbed almost 40 times, to quote the accounts at the time, butchered with virulent savagery. And then in the second half of the last episode, we talked about a second body, which was found in a narrow lane called Bucks Row, just before 4 o'clock in the morning on the 31st of August. and this is another woman who was lying on her back and the details, as they will be throughout this series, even more horrific. Her throat slashed from ear to ear,
在接下来的几集中，这是一个正被移民所改变的地区，特别是来自俄罗斯和波兰大屠杀的犹太难民。所以，为了真正回顾上一集的故事，汤姆，你描述了 8 月 7 日，一个叫玛莎·塔布拉姆（Martha Tabram）的女人在白教堂高街附近的一栋公寓楼里被发现遇害，她的尸体被刺了近 40 刀，引用当时的话说，被“极其残忍地屠杀”。然后在上一集的后半部分，我们谈到了第二具尸体，它是在 8 月 31 日凌晨 4 点前在一条叫巴克斯街（Bucks Row）的狭窄小巷里被发现的。这是另一个躺在背上的女人，细节正如本系列中一样，更加恐怖。她的喉咙从左耳到右耳被割开，
her body ripped open to reveal her intestines. And this was Mary Ann or Polly Nichols, very poor, alcoholic, homeless, possibly an occasional prostitute. And she's the first of the canonical five Ripper victims because really, although it's quite possible that Martha Tabram was also killed by the same man, it's with Polly Nichols that the press for Aurora begins
她的身体被剖开，露出了肠子。这就是玛丽·安（Mary Ann）或波莉·尼科尔斯（Polly Nichols），非常贫穷、酗酒、无家可归，可能偶尔从事卖淫。她是“开膛手五大受害者”中的第一位，因为虽然玛莎·塔布拉姆很可能也是同一个人杀的，但正是从波莉·尼科尔斯开始，媒体的狂热开始了，
and the Jack the Ripper phenomenon begins, I suppose, doesn't it? Yeah, and the police, as we mentioned in the previous episode, are at a complete loss. There are no clues. None of the people who lived in Bucks Row had seen or heard anything out of the ordinary. And the press, as you mentioned, I mean, they had, been fascinated by the murder of Martha Tabram. It has received quite a lot of coverage, a unique and mysterious crime because of its sheer savagery, the East London Observer said.
开膛手杰克的现象也随之开始了，我想是这样吧？是的，而且正如我们在上一集中提到的，警方完全束手无策。没有任何线索。住在巴克斯街的任何人都没有看到或听到任何异常情况。而媒体，正如你提到的，他们对玛莎·塔布拉姆的谋杀案非常着迷。正如《东伦敦观察家报》（East London Observer）所说，这是一起因其纯粹的野蛮行径而独特且神秘的犯罪。
And because of that, and because you now have a second killing, the newspapers immediately assume that both Martha and Polly have been killed by the same person and that this person must be a lunatic or perhaps someone of blood-drinking, vampiric, cannibalistic tastes. Yes. So when the evening pollies found, the Evening Star, which is the biggest evening paper in Britain, runs the banner headlines, revolting murder, another woman found horribly mutilated in Whitechapel, ghastly crimes by a maniac. And Dominic, then, as now, these are the kind of headlines that are guaranteed to get readership,
正因为如此，也因为现在有了第二起杀人案，报纸立即推测玛莎和波莉都是同一个人杀的，而且这个人一定是个疯子，或者是一个有嗜血、吸血鬼、食人倾向的人。是的。所以当波莉的尸体被发现时，英国最大的晚报《晚星报》打出了横幅标题：“令人作呕的谋杀，白教堂又发现一名被残忍肢解的女性，疯子的恐怖罪行”。多米尼克，当时和现在一样，这些都是保证能吸引读者的标题，
aren't they? They are indeed, absolutely. And the same paper comes back to the story in the next few days, so the very next day. In each case, the victim has been a woman of abandoned character. Each crime has been committed in the dark hours of the morning. And more important still, as pointing to one man and that man a maniac being the culprit, each murder has been accompanied by hideous mutilation. And the paper says, clearly these crimes are, quote, the work of some cool, cunning man with a mania for murder. They love a bit of a literate. in a late Victorian newspaper. The reason that we're quoting so much from the newspapers
不是吗？确实如此，绝对是。同一份报纸在接下来的几天里又回到了这个故事，就在第二天。在每起案件中，受害者都是品行不端的女性。每起犯罪都发生在凌晨的黑暗时刻。更重要的是，指向同一个人——一个疯子——作为罪魁祸首，每起谋杀案都伴随着可怕的肢解。报纸说，显然这些罪行是“某个有杀人狂热的冷静、狡猾的人所为”。维多利亚时代晚期的报纸很喜欢用头韵。我们引用这么多报纸的原因
is that they are absolutely central, not necessarily to the crimes, but to the Jack the Ripper phenomenon, to the historical phenomenon of the Jack the Ripper case. Because I think, as lots of Ripper historians think, this is as much a story about the newspapers and about publishing and indeed about mass literacy as it is one about crime or poverty or prostitution.
是它们绝对是核心，不一定是对犯罪本身，而是对开膛手杰克现象，对开膛手杰克案件的历史现象。因为我认为，正如许多开膛手历史学家所认为的那样，这既是一个关于报纸、出版业以及大众识字率的故事，也是一个关于犯罪、贫困或卖淫的故事。
And part of that, I think, is because so much of what we know about the murders actually comes to us from newspaper reports. Yeah. So not from official documents. Because a lot of those have been lost, haven't they? The inquest reports and so on. Exactly. So what we know of the inquests comes to us often through the newspapers or street scenes and so on. And there's a brilliant book on the Ripper case.
我认为其中一部分原因是，我们对谋杀案的了解大部分实际上来自报纸报道。是的。而不是来自官方文件。因为很多文件已经丢失了，不是吗？验尸报告等等。正是如此。所以我们对验尸的了解通常是通过报纸或街头场景等得知的。有一本关于开膛手案件的精彩书籍，
I think the definitive book, really, by a guy called Philip Sugden. If that name rings a slight bell, it's because he's actually the brother of the John Sugden, who's the design. definitive biographer of Nelson. I mean, imagine the discussions they have at Christmas. Yeah, incredible. So Philip Sutton's book is called The Complete History of Jack the Ripper. And, you know, it's I think by far the most scholarly and sort of serious book on this. And he points out that the newspapers in 1888 are competing for a new readership and
我认为是决定性的著作，作者是一个叫菲利普·萨格登（Philip Sugden）的人。如果这个名字听起来有点耳熟，那是因为他实际上是约翰·萨格登（John Sugden）的兄弟，约翰是纳尔逊勋爵的权威传记作者。想象一下他们在圣诞节时的讨论。是的，难以置信。所以菲利普·萨格登的书叫《开膛手杰克全史》（The Complete History of Jack the Ripper）。而且，我认为这是迄今为止关于此案最学术、最严肃的书。他指出，1888 年的报纸正在争夺新的读者群，
they're doing so with ever goria and more salacious stories. And so everything that we understand about the Jack the Ripper is coloured by that. And the context for this is that Britain has been transformed by the 1870 and 1880 Education Acts, which mandated state education and basically drove up adult literacy to 100% for the first time in history. So for the first time, Britain is genuinely a nation of readers. And the streets are awash with people selling, for example, penny dreadfuls. These are these cheap stories of crime and horror and adventure and mystery that are read over, overwhelmingly by young men and boys. And I think the entire reporting of the Ripper phenomenon,
他们通过越来越恐怖和耸人听闻的故事来做到这一点。因此，我们对开膛手杰克的所有理解都受到了这种影响。其背景是，英国通过 1870 年和 1880 年的《教育法》进行了转型，该法案强制实行国家教育，并基本上将成人识字率首次提高到了 100%。因此，英国首次真正成为了一个读者之国。街上到处都是兜售“便士惊悚小说”（penny dreadfuls）的人。这些是关于犯罪、恐怖、冒险和神秘的廉价故事，主要由年轻男性和男孩阅读。我认为对开膛手现象的整个报道，
including Jack the Ripper's name, owes a huge amount to these penny dreadfuls. So that's one thing to bear in mind. And then the other is the mass market newspaper. So newspapers are cheaper than ever before to produce new technology and so on. There's hundreds of competing titles. And crime and sex are absolutely central to their appeal. So one example that we'll come back to, the Palmao Gazette. Tom, tell us about the Palmael Gazette. There's a case for saying that the Palmael Gazette is the original tabloid newspaper of the kind that anyone who's read a British newspaper will be familiar with. And it was edited by a guy from Northumbria called WT Stead throughout the 1880s who ultimately would end up on Titanic. So that's a link between
包括开膛手杰克的名字，在很大程度上都要归功于这些便士惊悚小说。所以这是一件需要记住的事情。另一件事是大众市场报纸。报纸的生产成本比以往任何时候都低，新技术等等。有数百种相互竞争的刊物。犯罪和性绝对是它们吸引力的核心。我们稍后会回到的一个例子是《帕尔马尔公报》（Pall Mall Gazette）。汤姆，告诉我们关于《帕尔马尔公报》的事。有理由说《帕尔马尔公报》是原始的小报，任何读过英国报纸的人都会熟悉这种风格。它在 19 世纪 80 年代由一位来自诺森伯兰郡、名叫 W.T. 斯特德（W.T. Stead）的人编辑，他最终登上了泰坦尼克号。所以这是
the two stories. And he ran a series of incredibly sensational stories, boses, of which the most famous was a crusade against child prostitution. And these stories and campaigns have a direct knock-on effect on the program of slum clearance that is lapping at the borders of Whitechapel throughout this period and the closing of brothels. And we will be coming to him and his role in the story in a later episode. Yeah. But he's a key figure. So it's through papers like the Palmael Gazette and its competitors that people know about the murders. They both stoke and they report the fear and anger on the streets. So there's a great example.
这两个故事之间的联系。他刊登了一系列令人难以置信的耸人听闻的故事，其中最著名的是一场反对童妓的运动。这些故事和运动对这一时期在白教堂边界蔓延的贫民窟清理计划以及妓院的关闭产生了直接的连锁反应。我们将在以后的剧集中谈到他以及他在故事中的角色。是的。但他是一个关键人物。所以正是通过像《帕尔马尔公报》及其竞争对手这样的报纸，人们才知道了这些谋杀案。它们既煽动又报道了街头的恐惧和愤怒。这是一个很好的例子。
The 4th of September, the Daily News, sends a reporter down to Buck's Row, where the body was found. And he finds, or he says he finds, crowds of poor women who are sort of studying the paving stones for bloodstains. And he takes great glee in reporting what they say. I say reporting, but of course. He might be making it up. He might be making it up, right? Because it sounds often too good to be true, because he says,
9 月 4 日，《每日新闻》（Daily News）派了一名记者到巴克斯街，尸体就是在那里被发现的。他发现，或者说他声称他发现，成群结队的贫困妇女正在研究铺路石上的血迹。他以报道她们所说的话为乐。我说报道，但当然。他可能是编造的。他可能是编造的，对吧？因为这听起来往往好得令人难以置信，因为他说，
There's a little woman with a rosy cherub face who says to him, Life ain't no great thing with many on us, but we don't all want to be murdered. And if things go on like this, it won't be safe for nobody to put their heads out of doors. And this is precisely the kind of thing the readers of the newspaper want East End women to say. But Dominic, I mean, there is also, I mean, it is expressive of a genuine sentiment of kind of horror and people rallying together, isn't it? And so there's huge crowds for Polly Nichols when she's buried in the, the city of London Cemetery, of course, in Ilford. And this was a woman who was on her own, and now at her death, there are people who
有一个长着玫瑰色天使脸庞的小个子女人对他说：“生活对我们许多人来说没什么大不了的，但我们并不都想被谋杀。如果事情继续这样下去，谁出门都不安全了。”这正是报纸读者希望东区妇女说的话。但是多米尼克，我的意思是，这也表达了一种真正的恐惧感和人们团结一致的情绪，不是吗？所以波莉·尼科尔斯在伊尔福德的伦敦市公墓下葬时，有大批人群。这是一个孤身一人的女人，现在在她死后，有很多人
think, well, you know, she was one of ours. It's not just made up, is it? Well, no, no, no. It brings out the latent sentimentality of the British silent majority. Do you not think of the British working classes that's always there. And of course, all of this, the genuine horror and fear on the streets, plus the press, puts enormous pressure on the police. And we haven't really talked that much about the police so far.
认为，好吧，你知道，她是我们的同胞。这不仅仅是编造的，对吧？嗯，不，不，不。它激发了英国沉默的大多数人潜在的感伤情绪。你不觉得英国工人阶级总是这样吗？当然，所有这些——街头真正的恐惧和恐慌，加上媒体——给警方带来了巨大的压力。到目前为止，我们还没有谈论太多关于警察的事情。
So I think in the popular imagination, there's a general sense that the police are either unbelievably incompetent or uniquely malevolent, don't you? I'd say they're incompetent. They're either the blundering fools of Sherlock Holmes, the Lestrade and his colleagues, who are always one step behind the murderer and, of course, any amateur private detective who went to investigate this case. And I think most serious historians are much more generous. and say, you know, the police are far from perfect, but they're actually, you know, in an age before modern technology, they're doing the very best that they can in an impossible situation. So to paint a picture, the Metropolitan Police was set up by Sir Robert Peel in 1829. If you think of the Mets catchment area, as it were, you're looking at
所以我认为在公众想象中，有一种普遍的感觉，认为警察要么是不可思议的无能，要么是独特的邪恶，不是吗？我会说他们是无能。他们要么是福尔摩斯笔下笨拙的傻瓜，雷斯垂德和他的同事们，他们总是比凶手慢一步，当然，还有任何去调查此案的业余私家侦探。我认为大多数严肃的历史学家要宽容得多，并说，你知道，警察远非完美，但实际上，在现代技术出现之前的时代，他们在不可能的情况下尽了最大的努力。为了描绘一幅图景，伦敦警察厅是由罗伯特·皮尔爵士在 1829 年建立的。如果你考虑一下伦敦警察厅的管辖范围，你会看到
around about, about 6 million people, and they have 15,000 men to do it. Of course, they are all men. Now, today, the vet has 43,000 people policing about 8.5 million people. So they're comparatively understaffed back in the 1880s. They, in some ways, they're very modern organisation. So their police stations are linked by telegraph. But they're still working out of the sort of original, very cramped, sort of office building in Whitehall, Scotland Yard. And in recent months, in particular, they've become. very controversial. You mentioned in the last episode the chief commissioner of the Met, Sir Charles
大约 600 万人，而他们只有 1.5 万人来负责。当然，他们全是男性。现在，今天，伦敦警察厅有 4.3 万人负责约 850 万人的治安。所以他们在 19 世纪 80 年代相对人手不足。他们在某些方面是一个非常现代的组织。所以他们的警察局通过电报连接。但他们仍然在白厅苏格兰场那座原始的、非常狭窄的办公楼里工作。而且在最近几个月，特别是，他们变得
Warren. He's come from a military background, hasn't he? So he's served two terms in South Africa, but also just because it will feed into some of the theories that we'll be talking about in our final episode, he is a Freemason and he has an obsessive interest in the site of the temple in Jerusalem, which is fundamental to Freemasonry. And he was actually, he'd spent a term in Palestine and had conducted the first serious archaeological excavation of Temple Mount, the site of the temple. So I just throw that out as some contextualization. Maybe that's an important clue, or maybe it's a mad red herring, but we'll find out.
非常有争议。你在上一集中提到了伦敦警察厅的总监查尔斯·沃伦爵士（Sir Charles Warren）。他有军事背景，不是吗？所以他在南非服役了两届，而且——仅仅因为这会融入我们将要在最后一集中讨论的一些理论——他是一名共济会成员，他对耶路撒冷圣殿遗址有着痴迷的兴趣，这对于共济会来说是根本性的。他实际上在巴勒斯坦待过一段时间，并对圣殿山（Temple Mount）——圣殿遗址——进行了第一次严肃的考古发掘。所以我只是把它作为一些背景资料抛出来。也许这是一个重要的线索，或者也许是一个疯狂的红鲱鱼，但我们会发现的。
Anyway, he's been trying to modernize the Met, reflecting his military background. He's been trying to centralize it, to bring in more military discipline, and to bring in more people from the army. And at the same time, the Met has been dragged into politics. So, for example, you talked last time about the bloody Sunday, sort of the homeless camp, the demonstrations, the police had cracked down on it. And radical papers have ever since been painting the police as a tool of the capitalist establishment, you know, a tool of repression of the working class. It's literally like listening to Theo Young Smith, their producer, isn't it? So the police have been getting a lot of stick and they're in a very difficult place. Now, these murders are a massive
无论如何，他一直试图使伦敦警察厅现代化，反映了他的军事背景。他一直试图将其集中化，引入更多的军事纪律，并从军队中引入更多的人。与此同时，伦敦警察厅也被卷入了政治。例如，你上次谈到了“血腥星期日”、无家可归者营地、示威活动，警察对此进行了镇压。从那时起，激进报纸一直把警察描绘成资本主义体制的工具，你知道，镇压工人阶级的工具。这简直就像在听他们的制片人西奥·杨·史密斯（Theo Young Smith）说话，不是吗？所以警察一直受到很多指责，他们处境非常困难。现在，这些谋杀案是一个巨大的
challenge for the police as they would be today, but even more so. So to remind people, the crimes so far have been carried out in this warren of very poor, very narrow streets at night with no witnesses. The killer, they assume, works alone. I mean, I think this is what most people who studied the Jack the Ripper murders still believe there was just one person. He has no accomplices. He leaves no trace and no clues. He has no obvious motive. That's the key thing, isn't it? Yeah. Now, today, people would say out, but there's an obvious motive of serial killers. Do have motives. They're mad. But people don't have a sense of this in the 1880s. The studies have not yet been done on serial killers. So people are bewildered and horrified. This is why
对警察的挑战，就像今天一样，但更是如此。所以提醒大家，到目前为止，这些罪行都是在晚上在这些非常贫穷、非常狭窄的街道迷宫中进行的，没有目击者。他们推测凶手是单独行动的。我的意思是，我认为这是大多数研究开膛手杰克谋杀案的人仍然相信的，即只有一个人。他没有同伙。他不留痕迹，也没有线索。他没有明显的动机。这是关键，不是吗？是的。现在，今天，人们会说“啊，但连环杀手有明显的动机”。他们有动机。他们是疯子。但在 19 世纪 80 年代，人们对此没有概念。关于连环杀手的研究还没有完成。所以人们感到困惑和恐惧。这就是为什么
there's so much talk of him being a maniac. And to make him, matters more difficult for the police, the people he kills and their friends are the kind of people who generally keep, as it were, to the shadows of society. They are down and outs. They're poor. They're homeless. They've maybe been in trouble with the police. They're part of the sort of the underclass, as it were. So all of this means that it's a tough case to solve. Police forces today find such cases very difficult to solve. But in 1888, the CID, the criminal investigation, department. They are only 10 years old. They can't test blood. There's no fingerprint bureau that doesn't get opened until 1901. And they don't have a science laboratory.
有这么多关于他是疯子的说法。而且让警察更困难的是，他杀害的人和他们的朋友通常是那些在社会阴影中生活的人。他们是落魄者。他们很穷。他们无家可归。他们可能和警察有过麻烦。他们是所谓的下层阶级的一部分。所以所有这些意味着这是一个很难解决的案件。今天的警察部队发现此类案件非常难以解决。但在 1888 年，刑事调查部（CID）才 10 岁。他们无法检测血液。没有指纹局，直到 1901 年才开放。而且他们没有科学实验室。
They don't have any form of laboratory and they won't have one for another 40 years. So as Philip Sugden, to quote him, says, the odds were in favor of Jack the Ripper from the very beginning. You don't have to believe there's a cover-up or a conspiracy. It would have been a very difficult case to solve. But also, just to throw into the mix, there's also the evident fact that the murder is incredibly audacious, very opportunistic, and clearly, I think, very lucky. Yes, I think so. These are all factors that are making it more difficult for the police. Exactly. So now at this stage, the police, I think, it's just two murders as far as they're concerned, if you count Martha Tabram. And they see no great cause for alarm. So Sir Charles Warren has been on holiday in France, and they've just brought in a new guy, Dr. Robert Anderson, as assistant commissioner and head of CID.
他们没有任何形式的实验室，而且在未来 40 年内都不会有。所以正如菲利普·萨格登所说，胜算从一开始就站在开膛手杰克这一边。你不必相信有什么掩盖或阴谋。这本来就是一个非常难解决的案件。但也要补充一点，还有一个明显的事实，即谋杀案极其大胆、非常投机，而且显然，我认为，非常幸运。是的，我想是这样。这些都是使警察工作更加困难的因素。正是如此。所以现在在这个阶段，警察，我认为，就他们而言，这只是两起谋杀案，如果你算上玛莎·塔布拉姆的话。他们认为没有引起恐慌的重大理由。所以查尔斯·沃伦爵士一直在法国度假，他们刚刚聘请了一个新人，罗伯特·安德森博士（Dr. Robert Anderson）担任助理局长和刑事调查部负责人。
But on the 7th of September, he leaves for a month's holiday in Switzerland. When he takes the job, he says, sure, I'll take the job, but I'd like to go on holiday in Switzerland first. And they later get a lot of stick for this. But of course, it never occurs to them at the time that these, you know, apparently inconsequential killings in the East End will become defining stories of late Victorian Britain. Why would it? As far as they're concerned, these are two kind of homeless women or whatever had been murdered. so what? They've gone on holiday. But the newspapers, I think it's pretty clear, are itching for the next installments because they can see that this is going to be a big story. Because this is how
但在 9 月 7 日，他去瑞士度假一个月了。当他接受这份工作时，他说：“当然，我会接受这份工作，但我先想去瑞士度假。”他们后来因此受到了很多指责。但当然，当时他们从未想到，这些在东区发生的看似无关紧要的杀人案会成为维多利亚时代晚期英国的定义性故事。为什么会呢？就他们而言，这是两个无家可归的女人被谋杀了，那又怎样？他们去度假了。但报纸，我认为很清楚，渴望接下来的连载，因为它们可以看出这将是一个大新闻。因为这就是
the Victorian publishing industry works, isn't it, through installments. Yeah. And, you know, if you're kind of waiting for the next chapter in the story, then when it happens, you're going to go massive with it. Of course. And you get a sense of them, they're desperate for it to happen. And so the East London advertised, we've quoted that already. This came on the streets, this newspaper, on the morning of Saturday, the 8th of September. Throughout the week, the interest in the Whitechapel murder has been kept at fever heat. The murderer must creep out from somewhere. He must patrol the streets in search of his victims.
维多利亚时代的出版业运作方式，不是吗，通过连载。是的。而且，如果你在等待故事的下一章，那么当它发生时，你就会大肆报道。当然。而且你能感觉到他们，他们渴望它发生。所以《东伦敦广告报》（East London Advertiser），我们已经引用过了。这份报纸在 9 月 8 日星期六早上出现在街头。“整个星期，对白教堂谋杀案的兴趣一直保持在狂热状态。凶手一定是从某个地方爬出来的。他一定在街上巡逻寻找受害者。”
Doubtless, he's out night by night. Every woman in those parts goes in nightly danger of her life as long as he remains at large. So here's a thought. Yeah. What if it's a newspaper editor? to improve circulation. Yeah. That's a good thought, actually.
“毫无疑问，他每晚都在外面。只要他还在逍遥法外，那些地方的每个女人每晚都处于生命危险之中。”所以有一个想法。是的。如果他是报纸编辑呢？为了提高发行量。是的。这确实是个好主意。
Throw that into the mix. Listeners can let Tom know what they think of that suggestion. They don't need to let me know, just let Tom know personally. I think I might have contributed what is very unusual in riparology, an original theory there. Wow, that's exciting. Well, listen, even as people were reading those words in the East London advertiser, that the murderer must creep out, he must strike again. On that Saturday morning, the news is spreading that just as predicted
把它加进去。听众可以让汤姆知道他们对这个建议的看法。他们不需要让我知道，只要亲自告诉汤姆就行。我想我可能在开膛手学中贡献了一个非常不寻常的原创理论。哇，那太令人兴奋了。好吧，听着，就在人们在《东伦敦广告报》上读到那些话时，凶手一定爬了出来，他一定会再次袭击。那个星期六早上，消息传开了，正如预测的那样，
the Ripper has struck again. Well, Dominic, the Whitechapel murderer. Yes, of course. You're right. He's not yet the Ripper. So the scene is 29 Hanbury Street in Spittlefields. And it's on the north side of the street. We're in the dilapidated three-story house at number 29.
开膛手再次袭击了。嗯，多米尼克，白教堂杀手。是的，当然。你是对的。他还不是“开膛手”。所以现场是斯皮塔佛德（Spittlefields）的汉伯里街（Hanbury Street）29 号。它在街道的北侧。我们是在 29 号那栋破旧的三层楼房里。
Almost every room of this house is rented by a different family. And that tells its own story. So it's a real warren of people. And to picture the house, at the back of the house, there are three stone steps that go down and a little yard and in the yard there is an outside toilet and there's a woodshed and the whole thing is enclosed by a wooden fence and it's very tight it's very narrow and that's saturday morning the 8th of september some of the people living in the house get out very early because
这栋房子的几乎每个房间都由不同的家庭租用。这本身就说明了问题。所以它确实是一个人的迷宫。要想象这栋房子，在房子后面，有三级石阶向下通往一个小院子，院子里有一个室外厕所，还有一个木棚，整个地方被木栅栏围起来，非常紧凑，非常狭窄。那是 9 月 8 日星期六，住在这栋房子里的一些人很早就出去了，因为
it's market day and they're going to work as you said before this is going to be a theme of this whole story yeah and one of them is a guy who's a carman which is a kind of cart driver called john davis he's a little man with a stoop and he rents the attic and he lives in the attic with his family. And he gets up when the Spittlefield church clock strikes 5.45 a.m. His wife makes him a cup of tea because he's going off to the Ledenhall Market. He goes downstairs and he notices that the door to the street is wide open. Now that's nothing unusual.
那是集市日，他们要去工作。正如你之前所说，这将是整个故事的主题。是的。其中一个人是一个马车夫，叫约翰·戴维斯（John Davis），他是一个驼背的小个子男人，他租了阁楼，和家人住在阁楼里。当斯皮塔佛德教堂的钟声敲响凌晨 5 点 45 分时，他起床了。他的妻子给他泡了一杯茶，因为他要去利登霍尔市场（Ledenhall Market）。他下楼，注意到通往街道的门大开着。现在这没什么不寻常的。
There's so many people living in the house. They're coming and going. They're working odd hours and things. So he shuts that door. Then he goes to the back door. The back door is closed. He goes out of the back door into the yard because he just, just wants to take some air before he goes off to work and he steps outside and he sees something
住在这栋房子里的人太多了。他们来来往往。他们工作时间不固定等等。所以他关上了那扇门。然后他走到后门。后门是关着的。他从后门走到院子里，因为他只是想在去工作前呼吸一下新鲜空气，他走到外面，看到了
terrible it's the body of a woman sprawled on her back between the steps and the fence and he rushes back through the house and into the street he hails some workmen the workmen come and look they're very shaken they go off to find a policeman and by the time of the policeman inspector joseph chandler arrives the place is packed so the house is suddenly alive there's loads of people in the corridors and the and stuff. But no one's gone out into the yard. They've left it alone. So he pushes through and he goes into the yard. He's the first person to inspect the body. And to quote his written report, and of course this will be very gruesome. So if you're listening to this in the car with small children, I mean, frankly, why are you listening to a podcast about Jack the Ripper with small
可怕的一幕。一个女人的尸体仰面躺在台阶和栅栏之间。他冲回房子，跑到街上。他招呼了一些工人，工人们过来查看，他们非常震惊，他们去寻找警察。当警察约瑟夫·钱德勒（Joseph Chandler）督察到达时，那个地方已经挤满了人。所以房子突然活跃起来了，走廊里挤满了人。但没有人走到院子里去。他们让它保持原样。所以他挤了进去，走进院子。他是第一个检查尸体的人。引用他的书面报告，当然这会非常可怕。所以如果你是在车里和小孩一起听这个，我的意思是，坦率地说，你为什么要和小孩一起听关于开膛手杰克的播客呢？
children? But anyway, you've been warned. He said, I at once proceeded to number 29 Hanbury Street and in the backyard found a woman lying on her back, dead, left arm resting on left breast, legs drawn up, abducted, small intestines and flap of the abdomen lying on the right side, above right shoulder, attached by a cord with the rest of the intestines inside the body. Two flaps of skin from the lower part of the abdomen lying in a large quantity of blood above the left shoulder, throat cut deeply from left and back in a jagged manner right around throat. So it's a hideous spectacle and it's confirmed by the police surgeon. Dr. George George Bags to Phillips, who's very highly respected and in his 50s, and he's an important person.
但无论如何，你已经被警告过了。他说：“我立即前往汉伯里街 29 号，在后院发现一个女人仰面躺着，已经死亡，左臂放在左胸上，双腿弯曲，外展，小肠和腹部皮瓣躺在右侧，在右肩上方，由一根绳子连接，其余肠子在体内。腹部下方的两块皮肤皮瓣躺在左肩上方的大量血迹中，喉咙从左后方以锯齿状深深割开，绕过喉咙。”所以这是一个可怕的景象，并得到了警察外科医生乔治·巴格斯·菲利普斯（Dr. George Bags Phillips）博士的证实，他非常受人尊敬，五十多岁，是一个重要人物。
Some of his thoughts about who might have done this kind of run right through this case. Phillips thinks that it's possible that the victim was strangled first, and then there was this terrible savage cut in her throat. And that is one of the factors that would have stopped there being kind of excessive blood loss. Exactly. And then the really shocking thing, the really gory thing, the abdomen was cut open. And basically the intestines were taken out and placed by the victim's shoulder.
他关于谁可能做了这件事的一些想法贯穿了整个案件。菲利普斯认为，受害者可能先被勒死，然后她的喉咙被残忍地割开。这就是导致没有大量失血的因素之一。正是如此。然后是真正令人震惊、真正血腥的事情，腹部被剖开了。基本上肠子被取出来放在受害者的肩膀旁。
And then Dr. Phillips finds that the victim's uterus, most of her bladder, and part of her vagina were completely removed with a kind of clean cut and taken away. Now, of course, I've called her the victim. But this was, let's remind ourselves, a living, breathing woman with an inner life of her own. And her name was Annie Chapman. and we will be talking about her life and what brought her to this position on our bonus episode for club members along with the lives of Elizabeth Stride
然后菲利普斯博士发现受害者的子宫、大部分膀胱和部分阴道被完全切除，切口很干净，并被带走了。现在，当然，我称她为受害者。但让我们提醒自己，这是一个有血有肉、有自己内心生活的女人。她的名字叫安妮·查普曼（Annie Chapman）。我们将在俱乐部会员的奖励剧集中讨论她的生活以及是什么让她陷入这种境地，以及伊丽莎白·斯泰德（Elizabeth Stride）和凯瑟琳·埃多斯（Catherine Eddows）——另外两名受害者的生活。所以如果你不是“历史即是如此”俱乐部的会员，你可以在 arresticitoria.com 注册，你将了解这些生活以及它们告诉我们关于维多利亚时代晚期世界的什么。但现在先做一个简短的总结，关于安妮。她 47 岁。她的一生非常悲惨。
and Catherine Eddows, two of the other victims. So if you're not a member of the Restis History Club, you can sign up at arresticitoria.com and you'll find out about these lives and what they tell us about the late Victorian world. But a quick summary, just for now, about Annie. She was 47. She'd had a very tragic life.
她的父亲是一名士兵，后来是一名男仆。她出生在伦敦西部。她嫁给了一名马车夫。实际上，正如波莉·尼科尔斯一样，诅咒是酗酒。她从小就喝酒。她有三个孩子，但因为酗酒、行为不检点等原因，她最终与丈夫分居。到 1888 年时，她处境非常糟糕。
Her father was a soldier and then a kind of a manservant. She'd been born in West London. She'd married a coachman. And as actually with Polly Nichols, the curse is alcoholism. She's been a drinker from a young age. She has three children, but she ends up separating from her husband because of drink, because of disorderly conduct and whatnot. By the time she gets to 1888, she's very badly off.
她还患有肺结核，不是吗？是的，肺结核。她从一个廉租房漂泊到另一个。我们可以在奖励剧集中讨论她是否是妓女。我们所知道的是，在 9 月 7 日下午，她花光了钱。她对她的一个朋友说：“我需要去弄点钱。否则，我就没地方住了。”所以和波莉·尼科尔斯非常像。
She's ill with tuberculosis as well, isn't she? Yeah, tuberculosis. She's kind of drifting from one Doss House to another. We can discuss in the bonus episode whether or not she is a prostitute. What we do know is on the afternoon of the 7th of September, she'd run out of money. She said to a friend of hers, I need to go and get some money. Otherwise, I shall have no lodgings. So very like polynickels.
我的意思是，几乎一模一样。正是如此。她确实弄到了一些钱，是通过乞讨还是通过出卖性服务，我们不知道。但后来她把钱花在喝酒上，而不是住宿上。那个决定让她付出了生命的代价。所以又像波莉一样。是的，因为她被赶出了多塞特街（Dorset Street）35 号的廉租房。她在凌晨 2 点前走到街上，可能是为了赚取床位费。
I mean, almost identical. Exactly. She did get some money, whether through begging or through selling sexual services, we don't know. But then she spent the money on drink instead of lodgings. and that decision cost to her life. So again, like Polly. Yeah, because she was kicked out of her lodging house on 35 Dorset Street. She goes out just before 2 a.m. onto the streets, probably to earn the coppers for a bed.
她最后的遗言是：“我很快就会回来。别让床……”我说，多米尼克，从安妮·查普曼的尸体被发现的那一刻起，警方就意识到他们正在处理同一个杀手，他杀害了波莉，绝对是，可能还有玛莎。是的。他们指派了负责调查波莉·尼科尔斯死亡案件的同一位督察来负责此案。
And her last words, I shall soon be back. Don't let the bed. I said, Dominic, right from the moment that Annie Chapman's body is discovered, the police recognize that they are dealing with the same killer who had dispatched Polly, definitely, and probably Martha before her. Yes. And they assigned to the case the same inspector who is handling the investigation into Polly Nichols' death.
这是一个叫弗雷德里克·阿伯林（Frederick Abiline）的人，现年 45 岁。他来自多塞特郡，是一名职员的儿子，他经常出现在开膛手故事的流行版本中，不是吗？他被描绘成一个酗酒者，或者对妓女有奇怪的痴迷，或者是一个滑稽的无能者。虽然在电影《来自地狱》（From Hell）中，他由约翰尼·德普（Johnny Depp）饰演，是一个鸦片成瘾者，能窥见案件真相。约翰尼·德普有他非常精致的五官和颧骨等等。在现实中，阿伯林长得像个银行经理。所以他非常结实。他脸很圆。而且他留着极其巨大的维多利亚式胡子。
And this is a guy called Frederick Abiline, who is age 45. He's from Dorset, the son of a clerk, and he is often produced, isn't he, in kind of popular versions of the Ripper story. And he's kind of portrayed as an alcoholic or weirdly obsessed with prostitutes or being comically incompetent. Although in the film From Hell, he's portrayed by Johnny Depp as an opium addict who sees glimpses into the truth of the actual case. And Johnny Depp has his very fine features and his cheekbones and everything. In reality, Abiline had the appearance of a bank manager. So he's very stocky. He's very round-faced. And he has an absolutely colossal Victorian moustache.
他确实留着。是的，我们在节目中喜欢漂亮的胡子。我不得不说，这让我对阿伯林很有好感。我认为阿伯林在这个案件的流行历史版本中受到了非常、非常不公平的对待。因为我们拥有的所有证据都表明他是一个非常、非常优秀的警察。他之所以能晋升，正是因为他能干、高效、可靠。而且他像了解自己的手背一样了解斯皮塔佛德，不是吗？他确实非常了解。他是一个老东区通。他在 19 世纪 70 年代末和 80 年代初负责白教堂的刑事调查部。他是负责此案的显而易见的人选，因为他了解该地区，他在那里有联系人，而且他将在这个案件上付出难以置信的努力。你知道，他几天几夜不睡觉，被文件淹没了，
He does. Yeah, we like a good moustache on this show. And that endears Abiline to me, I have to say. I think Abiline is really, really hard done by in the sort of pop history versions of this case. Because all the evidence we have is that he was a very, very good policeman. He had risen through the ranks precisely because he was competent, efficient, reliable. And he knows Spittle feels like the back of his hand, doesn't he? He genuinely does. He's an old East End hand. He'd been in charge of the CID in Whitechapel. in the late 1870s and early 1880s. He is the obvious man to put on this case because he knows the area, he has contacts there, and he will go on to work incredibly hard on this case. You know, he goes for days without sleep, and he's drowning in paper and stuff,
他正在尽他最大的努力。所以把他说成是那种沉迷于妓女的瘾君子真是太疯狂了。是的，而且我认为他受到同僚的高度评价。他确实提出了两个关于开膛手可能是谁的非常有影响力的理论，我们将在适当的时候探讨。所以他面临的问题和以前一样，就是没有线索。当地的租户，住在汉伯里街 29 号的人什么也没看见。这具尸体只是在一夜之间出现在院子里，他们不知道它是怎么到那里的。
and he's doing his absolute best. So it's really harsh for these sort of, you know, to portray him as this sort of prostitute crazed drug addicts is bonkers. Yeah, and I think he is highly regarded. by his peers and he does come up with two quite influential theories as to who the Ripper might have been which again we will be exploring in due course so the problem that he faces as before is that there are no clues the local tenants the people living in 29 hambury street have seen nothing this body has just appeared in the yard overnight and they don't know how it got there
当然，邻居们，警察和每一个邻居都谈过了，他们中没有人看到任何人行为可疑，或者手或衣服上有血迹等等。然而，有三个重要的证人，所以我们应该花点时间看看这些人说了什么。第一个是叫约翰·理查森（John Richardson）的集市搬运工，他的母亲租了 29 号的底层房间。现在，她曾遭遇过入室盗窃，在这个地区非常普遍，所以每个集市日的早晨他都会去看看，只是检查一下她地窖的门，看看它是否，你知道，
none of the neighbors of course the police talk to every single neighbor none of them have seen anybody acting suspiciously or with bloodstained hands or clothes or whatever. However, there are three important witnesses, so we should take a bit of time to look at what these people say. The first one is a market porter called John Richardson, and his mother rented the ground floor rooms at number 29. Now, she'd had a break-in, you know, very common in this area, and so every market morning he would go to look, just check the door of her cellars, see that it was, you know,
当然，邻居们什么都没看到。警察和每一位邻居都谈过话，但没人看到有人举止可疑，或者手上、衣服上沾有血迹之类的。不过，有三位重要的证人，所以我们应该花点时间看看这些人说了些什么。第一位是名叫约翰·理查森的市场搬运工，他母亲租了29号楼的底层房间。当时她家里遭了入室盗窃，你知道的，这在这一带很常见，所以每天早上赶集时，他都会去查看一下，检查一下她家地窖的门，看看是不是，你知道的，
locked. And he'd done so this morning. He'd actually gone out into the yard just before five o'clock in the morning to fix his boot. And he didn't see a body. So that means that Annie must have died after five o'clock. Unless he did it. Well, unless he did it, I suppose. So we've got quite a narrow window of time now because that bloke who found the body, remember, he heard the Spittlefield's clock toll 545. So we're narrowing down the window. The second witness is a local woman called Elizabeth Long. And at about 5.30 in the morning, she'd been walking along Hanbury Street to Spittlefield's market, and she'd seen a man and woman talking outside number 29, and she later went to
锁上了。他今天早上确实这么做了。他实际上在凌晨五点前就去院子里修理他的靴子了。但他没有看到尸体。所以这意味着安妮一定是在五点之后遇害的。除非是他干的。好吧，我想除非是他干的。所以我们现在的时间窗口非常狭窄，因为那个发现尸体的人，记得吗，他听到了斯皮塔佛德钟楼敲响了五点四十五分。所以我们正在缩小时间范围。第二位证人是一位名叫伊丽莎白·朗的当地妇女。大约在凌晨五点半，她沿着汉伯里街走向斯皮塔佛德市场，看到一男一女在29号门外交谈，后来她去了
the mortuary, and she positively identified the woman as Annie Chapman. I mean, that's a very narrow window, then. Yes. It's only 15 minutes, isn't it? I mean, less than 15 minutes. So if she's right, and I think she probably is right, then the murder must be. be committed between about 530 and 545. And not only does she say this woman was Annie she gives us a pretty good description of the man that was talking to Annie. And I'll quote
停尸房，她明确辨认出那个女人就是安妮·查普曼。我的意思是，那时间窗口真的很窄。是的。只有15分钟，对吧？我的意思是，不到15分钟。所以如果她是正确的，而且我认为她很可能是正确的，那么谋杀一定是在五点半到五点四十五分之间发生的。而且她不仅说这个女人是安妮，她还给了我们一个关于那个与安妮交谈的男人的相当不错的描述。我来引用一下
it, he was dark complexioned and wearing a brown deer stalker hat. I think he was wearing a dark coat. He was a man over 40 as far as I could tell. He seemed to be a little taller than the deceased. Now Annie was quite short. She was five foot tall. He's only a little taller. So he's maybe you know, 5-3, 5-4, 5-5, something like that. He looked to me like a foreigner as well as I could make out. Hard to say what that means. He looked what I should call shabby genteel. Philip Sugden in his brilliant book on the Jack the Ripper case says,
，他肤色黝黑，戴着一顶棕色的猎鹿帽。我想他穿了一件深色外套。据我所知，他是一个四十多岁的人。他看起来比死者稍微高一点。安妮个子很矮。她只有五英尺高。他只比她高一点点。所以他可能，你知道，五英尺三、四、五英寸左右。据我所能辨认的，他看起来像个外国人。很难说这意味着什么。他看起来像我所说的落魄绅士。菲利普·萨格登在他那本关于开膛手杰克案的精彩著作中说，
this man was the murderer. This is what the murderer looks like. And actually, in the next couple of episodes, we'll be describing other witnesses and other murders who see similar-looking men, short, mustache, Dear Stalker hat, you know, this is a common kind of description, isn't it? It's a common profile, Tom. Yeah. And one thing that he is, not, by the way, he's not tall. And there's no sense whatsoever really important and probably disappointing for the conspiracy theorist community among our listeners. He's not an aristocrat. He's not wearing a top hat or an opera cloak. He's not carrying a medical bag. He is none of those things. Although witnesses will in due course, claim to have seen such a man. They will indeed.
这个人就是凶手。这就是凶手的样子。实际上，在接下来的几集里，我们将描述其他证人和目击者，他们看到了长相相似的男人，矮个子、留着胡子、戴着猎鹿帽，你知道，这是一种常见的描述，不是吗？这是一个常见的画像，汤姆。是的。顺便说一句，有一点他不是，他不高。而且完全没有那种对我们听众中的阴谋论者群体来说非常重要且可能令人失望的感觉。他不是贵族。他没有戴高礼帽，也没有穿歌剧斗篷。他没有提着医疗包。他什么都不是。尽管证人们最终会声称见过这样的人。他们确实会。
Yes, we'll be coming to that. Now, I said there are three witnesses. The third witness is a carpenter called Albert Kadoche. He lived next door to number 29 and number 27. He got up early and he said at about 520 or so he couldn't be sure. He went out into the yard and he heard low voices from over the fence and the only word he could make out was no. And then a few minutes later he said he heard a noise like and I quote,
是的，我们稍后会谈到这一点。现在，我说有三位证人。第三位证人是一位名叫阿尔伯特·卡多什的木匠。他住在29号和27号隔壁。他起得很早，他说大约在五点二十分左右，他不确定。他走到院子里，听到篱笆那边有低声交谈，他唯一能听清的词是“不”。然后几分钟后，他说他听到了一种声音，我引用一下，
something falling against the fence. then he left for work and as he passed Spittlefield's church he looked up and he saw the clock and he noted that it was 532 so that would seem to sort of tally you know Mrs Long sees the couple talking round about 530 then he similar time
有什么东西撞在篱笆上。然后他去上班了，当他经过斯皮塔佛德教堂时，他抬头看了看时钟，注意到是五点三十二分，所以这似乎吻合，你知道，朗太太看到那对夫妇交谈大约在五点半，然后他也在类似的时间
hears people talking in the yard and then he hears someone falling against a fence and then at 532 he looks up and sees the clock you know they're probably out each of them is out probably by a couple of minutes because people can never be precise about these things, but it seems to tally. So, remember that Annie had gone out to earn some money
听到院子里有人说话，然后听到有人撞在篱笆上，然后在五点三十二分他抬头看时钟，你知道，他们每个人可能都差了几分钟，因为人们对这些事情从来都不精确，但似乎吻合。所以，记住安妮是出去赚钱的
just around 2 a.m. So there are two possibilities. Possibility number one, Hallie Rubenhold in her book, The Five, she believes all the women were killed as they slept. So she thinks Annie just went into the yard of number 29. She lay down in a corner, went to sleep and was murdered as she slept. Philip Sutton, on the other hand,
大约在凌晨两点。所以有两种可能性。第一种可能性，哈莉·鲁本霍尔德在她的书《五人》中，她认为所有的女性都是在睡梦中被杀的。所以她认为安妮只是走进了29号的院子。她在角落里躺下，睡着了，并在睡梦中被谋杀。另一方面，菲利普·萨格登，
she went out to solicit to get customers, sometime around 5.30 just before 5.30 she fell in with the killer. He took her into the yard, or she took him into the yard, rather. Then he probably strangled her, lowered her to the ground, cut her throat, and then started the ripping process. Mrs. Long's testimony would suggest that is probably more feasible, wouldn't it? Definitely would. And I don't think Callie Rubenhold mentions Mrs. Long's testimony in her book, The Five. But I find it quite convincing. So a couple of quick observations from this before we take the break. Number one, as you've said, Tom, the Killam is incredibly daring.
她出去拉客，大约在五点半，就在五点半之前，她遇到了凶手。他把她带进了院子，或者说是她把他带进了院子。然后他可能勒死了她，把她放倒在地上，割断了她的喉咙，然后开始了开膛过程。朗太太的证词表明这可能更可行，不是吗？绝对是。而且我不认为卡莉·鲁本霍尔德在她的书《五人》中提到了朗太太的证词。但我发现它很有说服力。所以在我们休息之前，先做几个简短的观察。第一，正如你所说的，汤姆，凶手胆子大得惊人。
I mean, there's no doubt about that. The sun rose that day at 523. So it is light when he is going about his business. And it's as a market morning. There are loads of people moving around. Even as he and Ania are in the yard, people are getting up in the house and moving about. Yeah, which makes the question of motivation all the more striking. I mean, what is so desperate that he would take such incredible risks?
我的意思是，毫无疑问。那天太阳在五点二十三分升起。所以当他做这些事时，天已经亮了。而且这是一个市场早晨。有很多人在走动。即使当他和安妮在院子里时，房子里的人也正在起床走动。是的，这使得动机问题更加引人注目。我的意思是，到底是什么让他如此绝望，以至于冒这么大的风险？
Are the risks not the thrill? Is that not the thrill of it for him, do you think? But I'm just thinking in terms of the police. Yes. I mean, these are kind of dimensions of psychology that they're not really attuned to as yet. Of course not. They don't employ psychologists or anything like that. No.
难道风险不是刺激吗？你认为这对他来说不是刺激吗？但我只是从警方的角度考虑。是的。我的意思是，这些是他们尚未真正适应的心理层面。当然不是。他们不雇佣心理学家之类的。不。
Number two, the killer is incredibly quick and he obviously knows the area. So if he did this crime, you know, and did the disembarker, you know, and did the disemboweling and stuff. He's done it in a matter of moments. You know, no hesitation or anything. He's very fast. And then he gets away so quickly. And there's a really interesting little clue. There was a tap in the yard with a pail of clean water underneath. And it was still there after he had left. In other words, he didn't clean himself. He didn't turn the tap on because it would have had blood in it. So in other words, he has left covered presumably in blood. I mean, I know you don't bleed that much if you've been strangled and then stabbed. But the disemboweling would be
第二，凶手速度极快，而且他显然很了解这个地区。所以如果他犯下了这起罪行，你知道，进行了开膛破肚之类的。他是在片刻之间完成的。你知道，没有任何犹豫。他非常快。然后他逃跑得如此之快。有一个非常有趣的线索。院子里有一个水龙头，下面有一个装满干净水的水桶。在他离开后，它还在那里。换句话说，他没有清洗自己。他没有打开水龙头，因为那样水里会有血。所以换句话说，他离开时身上大概沾满了血。我的意思是，我知道如果被勒死然后被刺伤，流血不会那么多。但开膛破肚会是
gory work, right? Yeah. He's got away through the Warren of Streets carrying some of Annie Chapman's internal organs without being spotted. So he must know the area, right? Here's a spoiler alert. I think if you're a member of the royal family, you're going to get lost in that area and you're going to be spotted pretty quickly, frankly. Or a distinguished former prime minister or whatever. Yeah. Or if you're the elephant man, frankly, people are going to spot you. Yeah. Right. Finally, the killer knows what he's doing. This is a really, really important thing. Dr. Phillips said to take out those internal organs would have taken me an hour, you know, to do the surgery, to find them, all of this. The killer must have done it in moments, in minutes, you know,
血腥的工作，对吧？是的。他穿过迷宫般的街道逃走了，身上带着安妮·查普曼的一些内脏，却没有被发现。所以他一定很了解这个地区，对吧？这里有个剧透警告。我想如果你是皇室成员，你会迷失在那个地区，而且很快就会被发现，坦率地说。或者是一位杰出的前首相什么的。是的。或者如果你是象人，坦率地说，人们会发现你的。是的。对吧。最后，凶手知道他在做什么。这是一个非常非常重要的事情。菲利普斯医生说，取出那些内脏需要我一个小时，你知道，进行手术，找到它们，所有这些。凶手一定是在片刻之间，几分钟内完成的，你知道，
five minutes, three or four minutes. The coroner at the inquest said he must have been somebody who had considerable anatomical skill and knowledge. He basically knew what he wanted, where to find it, and how to use his knife. No unskilled person could have known where to find it, this is the victim's uterus, or could have recognized it when it was found. Now, that doesn't mean the victim must be a doctor or a surgeon, but it does mean it's somebody who knows a fair bit about anatomy and knows how to use a knife. So perhaps a butcher or a medical student or perhaps a slaughterman working in one of the knacker's yards or whatever. Exactly. So all interesting clues. Anyway, Annie is buried in secret on the 14th of September.
五分钟，三四分钟。验尸官在调查中说，他一定是一个具有相当解剖技能和知识的人。他基本上知道他想要什么，在哪里找到它，以及如何使用他的刀。没有受过训练的人不可能知道在哪里找到它，这是受害者的子宫，或者在找到它时能认出它。现在，这并不意味着受害者必须是医生或外科医生，但这确实意味着他是一个对解剖学相当了解并且知道如何使用刀具的人。所以也许是一个屠夫，或者医学生，或者也许是在屠宰场工作的屠夫之类的。正是如此。所以都是有趣的线索。总之，安妮在9月14日被秘密埋葬。
And by this point, Whitechapel is in a state of near hysteria and we'll come back to the heart of the East End after the break. Ella McKay, coming to theaters December 12th. Your father's here. Why? A heartwarming new comedy from James L. Brooks. I'm a different person. I have never been my life out this way about any other woman. Jesus! I wasn't counting your mother! It's a perfect holiday comedy about an imperfect family.
到这个时候，白教堂区处于近乎歇斯底里的状态，休息后我们将回到东区的中心地带。《艾拉·麦凯》，12月12日上映。你父亲在这儿。为什么？詹姆斯·L·布鲁克斯的一部暖心新喜剧。我是一个不同的人。我这辈子从来没有对任何其他女人这样过。天哪！我没算上你母亲！这是一部关于不完美家庭的完美节日喜剧。
You can use a scream, Ella. Starring Emma Mackey, Jamie Lee Curtis, Camel Nanjani, Iowa Debery with Albert Brooks and Woody Harrelson. You should do that every afternoon. Ella McKay. This episode is brought to you by Uber. Now, do you know that feeling when someone shows up for you when you need it most? We all need that sometimes, and Uber knows it. Uber isn't just a ride or a meal delivered.
你可以尖叫，艾拉。由艾玛·麦基、杰米·李·柯蒂斯、库梅尔·南贾尼、阿尤·艾德维利主演，阿尔伯特·布鲁克斯和伍迪·哈里森参演。你应该每天下午都这样做。《艾拉·麦凯》。本集由优步赞助。现在，你知道那种在最需要的时候有人为你挺身而出的感觉吗？我们有时都需要那样，优步知道这一点。优步不仅仅是乘车或送餐。
It's showing up no matter what. Like for your long-distance friends, bringing soup when they're sick, sending flowers when they're down. When it really matters, whatever it is, you. show up. Where there's a will, we're on our way. Uber, on our way. Download the app today. Hello and welcome back to the rest of history. We are in Whitechapel, East London and people on the streets of the East End and beyond are coming to terms with the fact that a second, And perhaps even third, gruesome murder has been committed by the man who is not yet called Jack the Ripper, but is already a massive star of the popular press. And the news breaks during the course of Saturday the 8th, and journalists, editors go berserk.
无论发生什么，它都会出现。就像为你远方的朋友，在他们生病时送去汤，在他们情绪低落时送去鲜花。当真正重要的时候，无论是什么，你都会出现。有志者事竟成，我们在路上。优步，在路上。立即下载应用程序。你好，欢迎回到历史的其余部分。我们身处伦敦东区的白教堂，东区及其他地区的街头民众正在接受这样一个事实：那个尚未被称为“开膛手杰克”但已经是大众媒体超级明星的男人，又犯下了第二起，甚至可能是第三起可怕的谋杀案。消息在周六8日传出，记者和编辑们都疯了。
And we were talking in the first half, Dominic. I mean, this essentially is their dream scenario. you've got another murder, and it seems to be even goryer than the previous one. So in our first episode, I quoted the Evening Star, which is the stuff about a ghoul stalking the streets of London and so on. This is when it runs. And the headline of that article was horror upon horror. Whitechapel is panic-stricken at another fiendish crime.
多米尼克，我们在上半场谈过。我的意思是，这基本上是他们梦寐以求的场景。你又发生了一起谋杀案，而且看起来比前一起更血腥。所以在我们的第一集里，我引用了《晚星报》，那是关于一个食尸鬼在伦敦街头徘徊之类的东西。这就是它刊登的时候。那篇文章的标题是“恐怖之上的恐怖”。白教堂区因又一起恶魔般的罪行而陷入恐慌。
And again, you can see that is absolutely calculated to fly off the newsstands. And it has to be said that the slightly posher, more quality broadsheets, as they would describe themselves, you know, they're piling in as well. So the Daily Telegraph, still going strong today at the time the best-selling newspaper in the world, it also buys into this kind of notion of the Gothic of the supernatural. It tells its readers that the East End is haunted by, and I quote, beings who look like men, but are rather dead. demons, vampires, and the result is exactly what the press wants. Mass hysteria, mass excitement, a demand to know more. Because there is a huge mystery. Who is doing this?
同样，你可以看出这绝对是经过精心计算，为了从报摊上抢购一空。必须说，那些稍微高档一点、自称为高质量的大报，你知道，他们也蜂拥而至。所以《每日电讯报》，至今仍在发行，当时是世界上最畅销的报纸，它也接受了这种哥特式、超自然的概念。它告诉读者，东区被，我引用一下，“看起来像人但实际上是死者的存在”所困扰，恶魔、吸血鬼，结果正是媒体想要的。大规模歇斯底里，大规模兴奋，要求了解更多。因为有一个巨大的谜团。是谁在做这些事？
Yeah, it is absolutely. So there are huge crowds at the murder sites or all the murder sites. There are crowds outside the mortuary, outside police stations. Reporters said that the crowds were particularly made up of women. and women would bring their children with them, you know. And that's actually a phenomenon that you often see. I mean, we've seen it in recent British history. Crowds of women outside, you know, murder sites and police stations and so on.
是的，绝对是。所以谋杀现场，或者所有的谋杀现场都有大量人群。停尸房外，警察局外都有人群。记者说人群中女性居多。而且妇女会带着她们的孩子，你知道。这实际上是你经常看到的现象。我的意思是，我们在最近的英国历史上也见过。谋杀现场和警察局外聚集着妇女等等。
Well, I think also, I gather that women are overwhelmingly the consumers of true crime podcasts. They are indeed, yeah. And going back to the golden age of detective fiction, largely read by women. Exactly so. Right to this day, true crime shows are watched or listened to by women. Interesting. I don't really have an answer for why that is, but it just is what it is. Some locals saw this as an opportunity to make money. So, as ghoulish as it sounds, the neighbours on Hanbury Street opened up their houses and they were charged visitors a penny ahead to come and look at the yard, to peer out at the yard of number 29. There was a man on Whitechapel Road who run a sort of despondent little waxworks exhibition.
嗯，我想我也了解到，女性是真实犯罪播客的绝大多数消费者。她们确实是，是的。回到侦探小说的黄金时代，很大程度上也是由女性阅读的。正是如此。直到今天，真实犯罪节目也是由女性观看或收听的。有趣。我真的没有答案为什么会这样，但事实就是如此。一些当地人把这视为赚钱的机会。所以，听起来很可怕，汉伯里街的邻居们打开了他们的房子，他们向每位游客收取一便士，让他们进来看看院子，窥视29号的院子。白教堂路上有一个人经营着一个令人沮丧的小型蜡像展。
Yeah, the poor man's man to swords. Yeah, and he got some red paint and daubed it on three waxworks. and he charged people a penny to come and see the George Yard, Bucksrow and Ambury Street victims. And there are loads of stories of kind of copycats and false alarms and people almost being lynched. So that very first evening, a man punches a policeman in the pub or something and is basically taken to the police station. And the word gets around, we've got the Whitechapel murderer. And so people pile in and they're desperate to lynch this bloke, basically, it's just had a fight in a pub. That's all it is.
是的，穷人的蜡像馆。是的，他弄了一些红油漆，涂在三个蜡像上。他向人们收取一便士，让他们来看乔治院、巴克斯罗和汉伯里街的受害者。而且有很多关于模仿者、虚假警报和人们差点被私刑处死的故事。所以就在第一个晚上，一个人在酒吧里打了警察什么的，基本上被带到了警察局。消息传开了，我们抓到了白教堂杀手。所以人们蜂拥而至，他们急于私刑处死这个家伙，基本上，他只是在酒吧里打了一架。仅此而已。
And there are some kind of properly suspicious people as well that the police are feeling their collars, right? Yeah, there are. So in the next sort of week or two, the police arrested nine different people and interrogated them on the suspicion that they might be the killer. And it's tempting to laugh at the police and say, oh, they got it wrong, which they did with all of these men. But it's instructive to look at who they arrested because it shows you how their minds are working. So to give a couple of examples, there's a German barber called Charles Ludwig who was arrested with a prostitute and he was carrying a clasp knife, a razor and a pair of scissors with him. Yeah, that's suspicious. You could say the tools of his trade or you could say she was terrified when police finally found them and she was worried that he was going to murder her and, you know, he fits to some extent, he fits the bill, right?
而且还有一些真正可疑的人，警察正在抓他们，对吧？是的，有。所以在接下来的那一两周里，警察逮捕了九个不同的人，并审问他们，怀疑他们可能是凶手。嘲笑警察说“哦，他们搞错了”是很诱人的，他们确实对所有这些人搞错了，但看看他们逮捕了谁是很有启发性的，因为它展示了他们的思维方式。举几个例子，有一个名叫查尔斯·路德维希的德国理发师，他和一个妓女一起被捕，他随身带着一把折叠刀、一把剃刀和一把剪刀。是的，那很可疑。你可以说这是他的职业工具，或者你可以说当警察最终找到他们时，她吓坏了，她担心他会谋杀她，而且，你知道，他在某种程度上符合条件，对吧？
It makes sense. Then there's a butcher, a pork butcher from Switzerland called Jakob Eisenschmidt. He was a drinker. He suffered depression. He would often sort of meaningfully sharpen his long knife at people, which I think didn't inspire great confidence. Again, suspicious behaviour. Yeah. And also he'd been in and out of lunatic asylums.
这说得通。然后有一个屠夫，一个来自瑞士的猪肉屠夫，名叫雅各布·艾森施密特。他是个酒鬼。他患有抑郁症。他经常会对着人意味深长地磨他的长刀，我认为这并没有激发太大的信心。同样，可疑的行为。是的。而且他曾多次进出精神病院。
And he had a strange habit of he would sometimes get hold of bullocks entrails and post them to his old shop as a sort of threat. I think the evidence is stacking up. And it's also interesting that both of those men are foreign. Yes. And Mrs. Long had said that the person that she'd seen talking to Annie Chapman, he looked to me like a foreigner. Yeah. And this sense of whether the Ripper is a foreigner or not becomes quite important to editorials and so on, because there's a kind of assumption that no Englishman could possibly be doing this, that it must be someone from abroad.
他有一个奇怪的习惯，有时会弄到公牛的内脏，并把它们寄到他以前的店里作为一种威胁。我认为证据正在堆积。而且有趣的是，这两个人都是外国人。是的。朗太太曾说，她看到与安妮·查普曼交谈的那个人，看起来像个外国人。是的。这种关于开膛手是否是外国人的感觉对社论等变得非常重要，因为有一种假设，即没有英国人可能做这种事，这一定是一个来自国外的人。
Absolutely, right. Absolutely. And the most significant of these early suspects is also somebody with an overseas background. And he is a shoemaker, a Jewish shoemaker, called John Paiser, who was arrested on the 10th. And he is the man who was mentioned in the last episode, because his nickname was Leather Apron. And in the days and weeks since the Polly Nichols murder, his name or his nickname had appeared a lot in the press. And the press had said, there's this bloke apparently called Leather Apron, who goes around, harassing prostitutes and threatening them and beating them up. It's such a terrifying name, isn't it?
绝对正确。绝对。这些早期嫌疑人中最重要的一位也是一个有海外背景的人。他是一个鞋匠，一个犹太鞋匠，名叫约翰·派泽，他在10号被捕。他就是上一集提到的那个人，因为他的绰号是“皮围裙”。在波莉·尼科尔斯谋杀案发生后的几天和几周里，他的名字或绰号在媒体上出现了很多次。媒体说，有一个叫“皮围裙”的家伙，到处骚扰妓女，威胁她们并殴打她们。这是一个多么可怕的名字，不是吗？
And I do think that in these cases, a suspect with a terrifying name ramps up the tension massively. Oh, definitely it does. So there was a hunt for this bloat leather apron. They find him at last, and he does tick a lot of boxes. He's 5'4, he has a very strong Polish accent, and he has a history of violence with a shoemaker's knife. And the police genuinely, I think at first think, this is.
我确实认为在这些案件中，一个名字可怕的嫌疑人会极大地加剧紧张局势。哦，绝对会。所以有一场对这个叫“皮围裙”的家伙的搜捕。他们终于找到了他，他确实符合很多条件。他身高5英尺4英寸，有很重的波兰口音，并且有使用鞋匠刀暴力的历史。我认为警察起初确实认为，这就是
is the guy. This is him. Yeah. But unfortunately, he has a pretty cast iron alibi for Polly Nichols's murder because he'd been staying at a lodging house and he'd gone outside with the owner of the lodging house to watch a fire at London docks. They'd watched it in the distance. And the bloke from the lodging house said, I absolutely know for sure I spent the evening with this bloke because we stood together watching the fire and talking about it. And with all of these people, with almost all of these people, they were still in custody when future murders happened. So the police could be certain that it wasn't them. But people start to mock the police
那个人。这就是他。是的。但不幸的是，他有一个相当铁证如山的波莉·尼科尔斯谋杀案的不在场证明，因为他一直住在一家旅馆里，他和旅馆老板一起出去看伦敦码头的一场火灾。他们在远处看着它。旅馆老板说，我绝对确定我那天晚上和这个家伙在一起，因为我们站在一起看火灾并谈论它。对于所有这些人，几乎所有这些人，当未来的谋杀案发生时，他们仍被拘留。所以警察可以确定不是他们。但人们开始嘲笑警察
so that the humorous magazine Punch produced a kind of parody called a detective's diary and they said, you know, oh, we heard that there's a rumor that the bloke wore a blue coat so we arrested everybody who wore blue coats. The blue coat people were innocent.
以至于幽默杂志《笨拙》制作了一种模仿，叫《侦探日记》，他们说，你知道，哦，我们听说有传言说那家伙穿了一件蓝色外套，所以我们逮捕了所有穿蓝色外套的人。穿蓝色外套的人是无辜的。
We heard it might be a soldier. We found a small drummer boy. We arrested him and all this kind of thing. Which is sort of mildly amusing, but it's not really fair because actually there is definitely method in their madness. Yeah, I mean, I think that if you're kind of going around thrusting daggers and knives in the face of prostitutes, I would arrest them.
我们听说可能是个士兵。我们发现了一个小鼓手。我们逮捕了他，诸如此类的事情。这有点好笑，但其实并不公平，因为实际上他们的疯狂中确实有方法。是的，我的意思是，我认为如果你到处在妓女面前挥舞匕首和刀子，我会逮捕他们。
Yeah, correct, exactly. So actually, of these people they arrested, three of them had been in asylums. Three of them were widely regarded as being of unsound mind. Five of them knew about anatomy. There might be butchers or slaughtermen or whatever. Interestingly, only three of them actually had been born abroad. So the element about being a foreigner, she's vague about that. She can't really explain why she thinks he's a foreigner. So the police clearly don't put as much weight on that. as they do on other elements of her testimony. Because obviously the police know that English people are perfectly capable of doing murders because they, you know, they're arresting murderers all the time. Yes, I think that's fair, actually. Now, this business about being a foreigner, though, it is incendiary because it's so dangerous for one group in particular. And this takes us back to the social background of Whitechapel.
是的，正确，正是如此。所以实际上，在他们逮捕的这些人中，有三个人曾住过精神病院。三个人被广泛认为精神不健全。五个人懂解剖学。可能是屠夫或屠宰工之类的。有趣的是，只有三个人实际上是在国外出生的。所以关于是外国人的那一点，她对此很模糊。她无法真正解释为什么她认为他是外国人。所以警察显然没有像对待她证词的其他要素那样重视这一点。因为显然警察知道英国人完全有能力进行谋杀，因为他们，你知道，他们一直在逮捕杀手。是的，我认为这很公平。现在，关于是外国人的这件事，它确实具有煽动性，因为它对一个特定的群体来说太危险了。这把我们带回了白教堂的社会背景。
Whitechapel has been transformed in the last 10 years, in particular, by Jewish immigration. So in 1881, Tsar Alexander II was assassinated in St. Petersburg and that kicked off wave upon wave of repressive anti-Semitic legislation
白教堂在过去10年里，特别是由于犹太移民而发生了转变。所以1881年，沙皇亚历山大二世在圣彼得堡被暗杀，这引发了一波又一波压迫性的反犹太立法
and then pogroms in the Russian Empire. And people are fleeing that and fleeing to Britain, in particular, on the United States. So in 20 years, the Russian and Polish population of London went from less than 9,000 people
然后是俄罗斯帝国的大屠杀。人们正在逃离那里，逃往英国，特别是美国。所以20年间，伦敦的俄罗斯和波兰人口从不到9000人
to almost 54,000 people concentrated above all in East End neighborhoods like Spitalfields or Myel End or Whitechapel. And if you read Jerry White's brilliant book on 19th century London, he talks about how there's an undercurrent of anti-Semitism all through this period. In some ways, quite small-scale stuff, it's kind of broken windows, it's graffiti, it's newspaper cartoons, it's kind of, you know, punch-ups on the street and stuff. But, you know, I said in the previous episode. There's been an economic depression, really, since the early 1870s. So there's a lot of job competitions, a lot of anxiety about people coming over here and stealing our jobs and
增加到近54000人，主要集中在斯皮塔佛德、迈尔恩德或白教堂等东区社区。如果你读过杰里·怀特那本关于19世纪伦敦的精彩著作，他谈到了这一时期一直存在反犹太主义的暗流。在某些方面，规模很小，比如打破窗户、涂鸦、报纸漫画、街头斗殴之类的。但是，你知道，我在上一集里说过。自1870年代初以来，一直存在经济萧条。所以有很多工作竞争，人们对来到这里抢走我们工作的人感到非常焦虑
whatnot. And so it's not surprising that straight away some of the newspapers and some people on the streets say, the killer must be a Jew. And that's one of the reasons why leather apron is such a kind of popular candidate to have been the murder, isn't it? Because he is Jewish. Yes, exactly. Exactly. And it's not surprising either that prominent Jews are then keen to push back. So the very first reward that was put up for the killer's capture was put up by Whitechapel's MP, who was a liberal, who was Samuel Montague, who was an Orthodox Jew and was a kind of proto-Zionist. And he put up £100 for the killer. And he was then backed up by a group called the Mile End Vigilance Committee, which will play a bit of a part in this
等等。所以难怪一些报纸和街上的一些人立刻说，凶手一定是个犹太人。这就是为什么“皮围裙”成为谋杀案的热门候选人之一的原因，不是吗？因为他是犹太人。是的，正是如此。正是如此。难怪杰出的犹太人随后急于反击。所以为抓捕凶手设立的第一个悬赏金是由白教堂的议员设立的，他是一位自由党人，名叫塞缪尔·蒙塔古，他是一位正统犹太教徒，也是一种原始的犹太复国主义者。他为凶手悬赏100英镑。然后他得到了一个名为“迈尔恩德治安委员会”的团体的支持，该团体将在本系列中发挥一定作用
whole series. And the Mile End Vigilance Committee was set up by local, largely Jewish traders and shopkeepers. And as we will see, they became nationally famous because they were to receive a letter and a hideous gift from somebody who may well have been the killer himself. From hell. From hell, exactly. Now, the police are not terribly keen on groups like this. First of all, the Home Office don't like rewards. Arguing about rewards, whether or not to give a reward, is a big, big part of the kind of police investigation. The Home Office hate rewards because they say, Basically, if somebody knew who the killer was, they'd tell us because his crimes are so horrible. And almost by definition, anyone who gives us information hoping for a reward is probably a hoaxer, and it's probably a false lead.
整个系列。迈尔恩德治安委员会是由当地主要是犹太商人和店主成立的。正如我们将看到的，他们变得全国闻名，因为他们将收到一封信和一份来自可能就是凶手本人的人的恐怖礼物。来自地狱。来自地狱，正是如此。现在，警察对这样的团体不太感兴趣。首先，内政部不喜欢悬赏。争论悬赏，是否给予悬赏，是警察调查中非常非常重要的一部分。内政部讨厌悬赏，因为他们说，基本上，如果有人知道凶手是谁，他们会告诉我们，因为他的罪行太可怕了。而且几乎根据定义，任何希望获得悬赏而提供信息的人都可能是骗子，这可能是一个错误的线索。
And actually, the weird thing is that Abilene and his colleagues, I mean, on the one hand, they wish they could have more clues. But on the other, they actually have too much information. Yeah. They have so many false leads and so many rumors and. and allegations and stuff. Well, I suppose, Dominic, that the fact that, you know, you were saying how there's a mass market now for the press means that there are vastly more numbers who can read these stories
实际上，奇怪的是，阿伯林和他的同事们，我的意思是，一方面，他们希望有更多的线索。但另一方面，他们实际上有太多的信息。是的。他们有太多的虚假线索和太多的谣言。以及指控之类的。嗯，我想，多米尼克，你刚才说现在媒体有一个大众市场，这意味着有更多的人可以阅读这些故事
and say, oh, it could be this or it could be that, or I've got this idea, or I've got that clue. So the letters just keep coming in, right? Of course. And, right, their filing system collapses under the strain. They have no computers. I mean, it's actually the same story, oddly, as what happened in the 1970s in West Yorkshire
并说，哦，可能是这个，也可能是那个，或者我有这个想法，或者我有那个线索。所以信件不断涌入，对吧？当然。而且，对，他们的归档系统在压力下崩溃了。他们没有电脑。我的意思是，这实际上是同一个故事，奇怪的是，就像1970年代在西约克郡发生的那样
with the Yorkshire Ripper, again, a pre-computer world where they were totally overwhelmed by too much information. So the days go by, there was no breakthrough, and the pressure begins to build on the authorities. So by the 14th of September, the star is calling the Home Secretary Henry Matthews, and I quote, a feeble mantabank who would pose and simper over the brink of a volcano. It's really like really one of my old columns, actually. Well, I mean, it's amazing to know that Home Secretaries were getting abuse back then, as they do now. Yeah.
与约克郡开膛手案一样，那是一个前电脑时代，他们被太多的信息完全淹没了。所以日子一天天过去，没有取得突破，当局的压力开始增加。所以到9月14日，《星报》称内政大臣亨利·马修斯，我引用一下，“一个虚弱的江湖骗子，会在火山边缘摆姿势和傻笑”。这真的就像我以前的一篇专栏文章，实际上。嗯，我的意思是，知道内政大臣当时像现在一样受到辱骂，真是令人惊讶。是的。
And even the telegraph, a Tory paper, which should be supporting him, said of Mr. Matthews, we've had enough of Mr. Matthews, who knows nothing, has heard nothing, and does not intend to do anything. I mean,
甚至《每日电讯报》，一份保守党报纸，本应支持他，却对马修斯先生说，我们受够了马修斯先生，他什么都不知道，什么都没听说，也不打算做任何事。我的意思是，
plus it change. Even so, you get to late September, and there is a sense, I think, that maybe the panic is easing, the authorities have weathered the storm, things are,
一切照旧。即便如此，到了九月下旬，我认为有一种感觉，也许恐慌正在缓解，当局已经度过了风暴，事情是，
you know, the killer has not yet struck again. It's a fine summer. You know, the weather has been dry, people are out and about some of the fear has dissipated and then on the 22nd of September another murder grips the public imagination another woman has been killed her name is Jane Bidmore but she has been stabbed and killed on a fell outside Gateshead in the
你知道，凶手还没有再次袭击。这是一个美好的夏天。你知道，天气一直很干燥，人们都在外面活动，一些恐惧已经消散了，然后在9月22日，又一起谋杀案抓住了公众的想象力，另一名妇女被杀，她的名字是简·比德莫尔，但她在英格兰东北部盖茨黑德外的一个荒原上被刺死
northeast of England they're a long way from the east end a long way hundreds of miles away Now, at first, there is speculation she's another victim of the Whitechapel murderer. As it turns out, she was actually murdered by her ex-boyfriend. She'd dumped him. It was a crime of passion, and he killed her. So like Mariah Martin in the Red Barn. Right. But at the time, people said, well, maybe this killer has moved north.
距离东区很远，很远，几百英里远。现在，起初，有人猜测她是白教堂杀手的又一个受害者。事实证明，她实际上是被她的前男友谋杀的。她甩了他。这是一起激情犯罪，他杀了她。就像红谷仓里的玛丽亚·马丁一样。对。但在当时，人们说，嗯，也许这个杀手已经搬到北方了。
So again, there's a sort of slackening of tension in the East End. And on the 27th of September, the Daily News sent a reporter to Whitechapel. and he wrote a long feature about the atmosphere. And he said, you know, a few days ago, he said people seem very, very shocked and very frightened. But now he says things are back to normal. And he paints, like you can look it up online. It's on the kind of casebook, Jack the Ripper casebook website, this story. And he paints a really vivid picture of Whitechapel, the steaming cookshops, the flaring gin palaces and noisy shows, the cheap jacks and shooting galleries, the streaming lights and roar and rattle and hurrying throngs and noisy.
所以东区的紧张局势再次有所缓解。9月27日，《每日新闻》派了一名记者到白教堂。他写了一篇关于气氛的长篇专题报道。他说，你知道，几天前，他说人们看起来非常非常震惊和害怕。但现在他说一切都恢复正常了。他描绘了，就像你可以在网上查到的一样。它在“开膛手杰克案例书”网站上，这个故事。他描绘了一幅非常生动的白教堂画面，冒着热气的熟食店，闪烁的杜松子酒宫和嘈杂的表演，廉价商品摊和射击场，流动的灯光和咆哮、嘎嘎声以及匆忙的人群和嘈杂的
groups. Dominic, we mentioned that it's the entertainment capital of the entire East End. So lots to do. And a lot of eccentric entertainment, shall we say. So he finds people crowding around a performing boy with no legs, for example, or a huge crowd around a trader who's selling trousers for nine shillings. And he stops in Hambrey Street, which is where Annie Chapman had been found, he stops an elderly passerby. And he says to this bloke, people don't seem very anxious about these murders. And the guy says to him, no, there's very little anxiety. People most of them, they think he's gone to Gateshead. But has he gone to Gateshead? Because that same day, the 27th, the editor of the Central News Office in London gets a letter written in red ink.
群体。多米尼克，我们提到它是整个东区的娱乐之都。所以有很多事情要做。而且有很多古怪的娱乐活动，我们可以这么说。所以他发现人们围着一个没有腿的表演男孩，或者一大群人围着一个卖九先令裤子的商人。他在汉伯里街停了下来，那是安妮·查普曼被发现的地方，他拦住了一位年长的路人。他对这个家伙说，人们似乎对这些谋杀案不太担心。那个人对他说，不，几乎没有什么焦虑。人们大多数人，他们认为他已经去了盖茨黑德。但他去盖茨黑德了吗？因为就在同一天，27日，伦敦中央新闻社的编辑收到了一封用红墨水写的信。
And that is the letter, Tom, with which we began the first episode. Do you want to read a couple of extracts to remind people? Yeah, so just to remind people of what he said. I keep on hearing, the police have caught me, but they won't fix me just yet. I'm down on oars, and I shall quit ripping them till I do get buckled. Grand work, the last job was I gave the lady no time to squeal. I love my work, I want to start again. You're so near of me with my funny little games. And he said that he'd saved blood from the last job, so Annie Chapman to write with,
那就是那封信，汤姆，我们用它开始了第一集。你想读几段来提醒大家吗？是的，只是提醒大家他说了什么。我一直听说，警察抓住了我，但他们还不会把我关起来。我情绪低落，我将停止开膛，直到我被抓住。上一份工作干得漂亮，我没给那位女士尖叫的时间。我热爱我的工作，我想重新开始。你离我那些有趣的小游戏太近了。他说他留下了上一份工作的血，也就是安妮·查普曼的血来写信，
but it went thick like glue and I can't use it. And then he says, the next job I do, I shall clip the ladies' ears off and send to the police. My knife's so nice and sharp, I want to get to work right away if I get a chance. So we said this is the most notorious letter in the entire history of crime. And the reason for its fame is the sign-off because it ends. Yours truly Jack the Ripper. Don't mind me giving the trade name. Yes.
但它变得像胶水一样浓，我没法用。然后他说，下一份工作，我将割掉女士们的耳朵并寄给警察。我的刀很锋利，如果我有机会，我想马上开始工作。所以我们说这是整个犯罪史上最臭名昭著的信。它出名的原因是结尾，因为它结尾是。你真诚的，开膛手杰克。别介意我用这个行业名称。是的。
and the reaction of the editor at the news agency to begin with is a hoax because obviously there have been lots of other letters that have been obvious hoaxes and so there is the you know this question hanging well was it a hoax or is it real? We'll come back to this in the next episode but most experts think it's a hoax
新闻机构编辑的反应起初是恶作剧，因为显然有很多其他的信件是明显的恶作剧，所以有那个，你知道，悬而未决的问题，它是恶作剧还是真实的？我们将在下一集回到这个问题，但大多数专家认为这是一个恶作剧
the killer never did cut off of victim's ears so he did mutilate a future victim Catherine eddows and cut off the lobe of one of her ears, but that was a minor thing compared with the other mutilations he carried out. Philip Sugton points out that this letter, people can Google it, they can see lots of examples of it online.
凶手从未割掉受害者的耳朵，所以他确实残害了未来的受害者凯瑟琳·埃多斯，并割掉了她一只耳朵的耳垂，但这与他进行的其他残害相比是小事一桩。菲利普·萨格登指出，这封信，人们可以谷歌一下，他们可以在网上看到很多例子。
The punctuation is all over the place, but there is not a single spelling mistake. So as Sugden says, it seems like the work of an educated man pretending to be an uneducated one. He thinks it's revealing that it's sent to a news agency, not the police. In other words, it's a letter sent
标点符号到处都是，但没有一个拼写错误。所以正如萨格登所说，这看起来像是一个受过教育的人在假装成一个没受过教育的人。他认为这封信寄给新闻机构而不是警察是很有启发性的。换句话说，这是一封信
not to taunt the police, but to get the maximum possible publicity. And Sulton also notes the postcode, the East Central Postcode, which covered Fleet Street, the offices of the major newspapers, and he thinks this is probably the work of a young reporter who is having a bit of fun and is hoping to generate a story. And that would tally with the Jack the Ripper nickname, because first of all, the ripping bits. of it, the ripper. The newspapers had used the word ripping and ripper a lot. They described the ripping open of the bodies. So somebody who's immersed in the world of newspapers, that would make sense. And then the second thing, Jack. Jack is the most common name for criminals in the
不是为了嘲弄警察，而是为了获得最大的宣传。萨格登还提到了邮政编码，东区邮政编码，覆盖了舰队街，主要报纸的办公室，他认为这很可能是一个正在找乐子并希望制造新闻的年轻记者的作品。这与“开膛手杰克”这个绰号相吻合，因为首先，开膛的部分。它，开膛手。报纸大量使用了“开膛”和“开膛手”这两个词。他们描述了身体被撕开的过程。所以一个沉浸在报纸世界里的人，这说得通。然后第二件事，杰克。杰克是罪犯中最常见的名字
penny dreadfuls that I mentioned in the first half. And of course, monkeys. And monkeys. Well, that occurred to me as well. So when we did our episode about history's greatest monkeys, a lot of them were called Jack. Jacko McCacko, Jack the Signalman, Corporal Jackie, and so on. Jack was a standard name that you reached for, you know, if you were creating a character, should we say. Yeah, and there's a hint of a kind of a rogue, a lad, an adventurer as well, isn't there? Jack the lad, exactly. So one of the most popular figures on the Victorian stage was the 18th century burglar Jack Shepherd. And there was also a kind of urban legend, I mean, it seems mad now that there would be such an urban legend, but it was very popular in the
我在上半场提到的“便士恐怖小说”中。当然，还有猴子。还有猴子。嗯，我也想到了这一点。所以当我们做关于历史上最伟大的猴子的那一集时，很多猴子都叫杰克。杰克·麦卡科、杰克信号员、杰克下士等等。杰克是一个标准的你伸手可及的名字，你知道，如果你正在创造一个角色，我们可以这么说。是的，而且还有一种流氓、小伙子、冒险家的暗示，不是吗？杰克小伙子，正是如此。所以维多利亚时代舞台上最受欢迎的人物之一是18世纪的窃贼杰克·谢泼德。还有一种都市传说，我的意思是，现在看起来很疯狂，竟然会有这样的都市传说，但在
sort of middle of the 19th century, an urban legend of somebody called Springheel Jack, who would kind of leap out and attack young girls and young women. Yeah, and kind of vanish in a blaze of fire. Yeah, and the sort of rumors of this character is the kind of thing kids will tell each other in the playground. There's this book called Spring Heel Jack who kind of leaps out and then vanishes again. The nickname is precisely the kind of nickname. I think that a young journalist who goes to the stage a lot, goes to the theatre, reads Penny Dreadfuls, would choose.
19世纪中叶，一个叫“弹簧腿杰克”的人的都市传说非常流行，他会跳出来攻击年轻女孩和年轻妇女。是的，并且在火光中消失。是的，这种角色的谣言是孩子们在操场上会互相讲述的那种事情。有一本书叫《弹簧腿杰克》，他跳出来然后又消失了。这个绰号正是那种绰号。我认为一个经常去舞台、去剧院、读便士恐怖小说的年轻记者会选择它。
And it's an exciting, newsworthy name. Yeah, and the evidence for that is that it goes viral, doesn't it? It does go viral, exactly, based not purely on this, right? So the editor of the Central News Agency doesn't think it's real, but two days later, he passes it to Scotland Yard anyway and says, you know, you might want to just check this out. And then that very evening comes the most dramatic episode of the whole story, one of the most gruesome nights in London's history. So we'll start in Burner Street, in the heart of Whitechapel. It's the evening of Saturday, the 29th of September. And we are at specifically a sort of courtyard called Dutfield's Yard, and it was enclosed by a row of cottages by a print workshop and by the International Working Men's Educational Club, which was a socialist club for Russian.
而且这是一个令人兴奋、有新闻价值的名字。是的，证据就是它疯传了，不是吗？它确实疯传了，正是如此，不仅仅基于这一点，对吧？所以中央新闻社的编辑不认为它是真的，但两天后，他还是把它交给了苏格兰场，并说，你知道，你可能想查一下。然后就在那天晚上，整个故事中最戏剧性的一集发生了，伦敦历史上最可怕的夜晚之一。所以我们将从白教堂中心的伯纳街开始。那是9月29日星期六的晚上。我们具体是在一个叫达特菲尔德院的庭院，它被一排小屋、一个印刷车间和国际工人教育俱乐部包围，这是一个为俄罗斯人开设的社会主义俱乐部。
and Polish Jews. And every Saturday night, this club had debates about socialism and whatnot. And it breaks up, the debate breaks up at about 11.30. Most people go, but a few of them stay upstairs in the reading room to chat. Now, in the other buildings around the yard, people are still working. So the print workshop, people are coming and going. The lights are kind of burning. At about 1240, the chairman of the Socialist Club, who's a guy called Morris Eagle,
以及波兰犹太人。每个周六晚上，这个俱乐部都会举行关于社会主义之类的辩论。辩论在11点半左右结束。大多数人都走了，但有几个人留在楼上的阅览室聊天。当时，院子周围的其他建筑里，人们还在工作。印刷车间里人来人往。灯火通明。大约12点40分，社会主义俱乐部的主席，一个叫莫里斯·伊格尔的人，
he comes into the yard, he's been walking a lady friend home. And he can hear someone singing in Russian upstairs at the club, perfectly normal. He goes through the gates, he goes through the yard, he doesn't notice anything strange in the yard at all. So this is, I'm telling you this because it gives people a sense of the wind over time. Then 20 minutes later, a man riding a little cart comes into the yard. And he's a Russian Jew called Louis Diemschutz. He's the steward of the club, and he lives there with his wife.
他走进院子，他刚才送一位女性朋友回家。他能听到楼上俱乐部里有人在用俄语唱歌，这很正常。他穿过大门，穿过院子，在院子里一点也没注意到有什么异常。我告诉你这些是因为这能让人感受到当时的风向。20分钟后，一个赶着小车的人进了院子。他是一个叫路易斯·迪姆舒茨的俄国犹太人。他是俱乐部的管家，和妻子住在那儿。
and he's been out selling jewelry all day. And he turns his cart into the yard and almost immediately the pony shies away. And he looks down to the right and he sees something huddled by the wall of the club in the darkness. And he prods this thing with his whip and it doesn't move and he lights a match and it's a human body. And he runs upstairs to the club to get help from his wife and so on.
他整天都在外面卖珠宝。他把车赶进院子，小马几乎立刻就受惊躲开了。他向右下方看去，看到黑暗中俱乐部的墙边蜷缩着什么东西。他用鞭子戳了戳那个东西，它没动，他划了一根火柴，发现那是一具人体。他跑上楼去俱乐部找他妻子帮忙等等。
And then he runs back. And as his wife later told the press, I at once recognized it as the body of a woman while to add to my horror, I saw a stream of blood. She was lying on her back with her head against the wall, and the face looked ghastly. And a crowd gathers, and they lift her head, they light a match, and they see a gash in her throat. They go and get the police. The police arrive.
然后他跑了回来。正如他妻子后来告诉媒体的那样，我立刻认出那是一具女尸，更让我恐惧的是，我看到了一滩血。她仰面躺着，头靠在墙上，脸色惨白。人群聚集起来，他们抬起她的头，划了一根火柴，看到她的喉咙被割开了。他们去叫警察。警察赶到了。
They bring a doctor. The doctor is there by about 1.15, and he says she's been dead for about 20 minutes or half an hour. So in other words, once again, this has happened very, very quickly. and then about half an hour later Detective Inspector Reid of the Metropolitan Police arrives and eventually they identify this woman her name is Elizabeth Stride will tell her story in the bonus episode for our club members
他们带来了一名医生。医生在1点15分左右到达，他说她已经死了大约20分钟或半小时。换句话说，这件事再次发生得非常非常快。大约半小时后，伦敦警察厅的侦探督察里德赶到，最终他们确认了这名女子的身份，她叫伊丽莎白·斯泰德，我们将在会员专属剧集中讲述她的故事。
just very briefly she's an immigrant herself she's from Gothenburg in Sweden she'd been a domestic servant then almost certainly in Gothenburg she was a prostitute she came to England she married a bloke called Stride they set up a coffee house which collapsed her marriage fell apart it's a very familiar story the spiral of poverty homelessness and so on she had cleaning jobs but she also definitely worked as a prostitute and she'd probably gone out soliciting that night hoping to get some money for lodgings again a very familiar story and there are intriguing witness reports that describe her talking to a man and we'll talk about them next time but for now let's rewind to the discovery of the body
简单来说，她自己也是一名移民，来自瑞典哥德堡，曾做过家庭佣人，几乎可以肯定她在哥德堡当过妓女。她来到英国，嫁给了一个叫斯泰德的家伙，他们开了一家咖啡馆，但倒闭了，婚姻也破裂了。这是一个非常熟悉的故事，贫困、无家可归等等的恶性循环。她做过清洁工，但也确实做过妓女，那天晚上她可能出去拉客，希望能赚点钱付房租，这又是一个非常熟悉的故事。有一些耐人寻味的目击者报告描述她当时正在和一个男人交谈，我们下次会谈到这些，但现在让我们回到发现尸体的时候。
in Dutfield's Yard. So that was just before 1 o'clock in the morning, right? But the drama is not yet over. So if we move the camera now, three quarters of a mile to the west, 12 minutes walk away, and we're now in another enclosed space, mitre square just off all gate,
在达特菲尔德院子里。那是凌晨1点之前，对吧？但戏剧性的一幕还没有结束。如果我们现在把镜头移到西边四分之三英里处，步行12分钟的路程，我们现在到了另一个封闭的空间，米特广场，就在阿尔盖特附近，
which is close to the eastern edge of the city of London. And this has a very different fear. It's not that far away. It's only 12 minutes walk. But the atmosphere is different. This is much more respectable. It's a square lined with offices and warehouses, and it's pretty empty. And it's in the city of London.
靠近伦敦城的东缘。这里的恐惧感截然不同。离得并不远。步行只需12分钟。但气氛不同。这里体面得多。这是一个两旁都是办公室和仓库的广场，相当空旷。而且它位于伦敦城内。
So there is a different police jurisdiction there. It's a much older centre of habitation, and the name Maita derives from the fact that a priory had stood on the site. Oh, nice. So it's this dull, lonely spot surrounded by offices and warehouses. And at 1.30, so we're talking about just over half an hour. after Elizabeth Stride's body was found. At 1.30, police constable Edward Watkins entered Mitre Square as part of his regular nighttime beat
所以那里的警察管辖权不同。这是一个更古老的居住中心，米特这个名字源于这里曾经有一座修道院。哦，不错。所以这是一个被办公室和仓库包围的沉闷、孤独的地方。在1点30分，也就是伊丽莎白·斯泰德的尸体被发现半个多小时后。1点30分，警员爱德华·沃特金斯作为他常规夜间巡逻的一部分进入了米特广场，
and he walks into the square and there's no sound but his own footsteps. And he looks around the square and there's nothing. Seems completely deserted. So he leaves the square at the far end and he carries on his beat and it takes him 15 minutes to come round. So now he's come round and he comes back into the square and it's 144.
他走进广场，除了自己的脚步声外没有任何声音。他环顾四周，什么也没有。看起来完全荒无人烟。于是他从广场的另一端离开，继续他的巡逻，他花了15分钟绕了一圈。现在他绕回来了，又回到了广场，时间是1点44分。
and again he hears nothing, and then by his own account, I turned sharp round to the right and flashing my light, I saw it in front of me. A more dreadful sight I never saw. It quite knocked me over. And he runs towards the nearest lit window, which is a warehouse on the far side. And there, the night watchman is sweeping up. And PC Watkins runs in and he shouts, For God's sake, mate, come to my assistance. There's another woman cut to pieces. Because for the second time in barely an hour, Jack the Ripper has struck again. But who, Dominic, has he slain and what further horrors may lie ahead? And rest his history, club members can find out right away, because the next three episodes,
他再次什么也没听到，然后据他自己描述，我猛地向右转，闪着灯光，我看到了它就在我面前。我从未见过如此可怕的景象。它完全把我击垮了。他跑向最近的亮着灯的窗户，那是远端的一个仓库。在那里，夜班看守正在打扫卫生。沃特金斯警员跑进去喊道，看在上帝的份上，伙计，快来帮我。又有一个女人被切碎了。因为在不到一个小时的时间里，开膛手杰克第二次作案了。但是，多米尼克，他杀害了谁，未来还会有什么恐怖的事情发生？历史就是这样，俱乐部成员可以马上知道，因为接下来的三集，
including the final episode in which we will be unmasking the identity of the murderer, are available to hear right now. And if you would like to hear them too and you're not signed up to the Restis History Club, then you can go to the Restis History.com and do so there. Thank you very much, Dominic. Thank you everyone for listening. Goodbye. Bye-bye.
包括我们将揭开凶手身份的最后一集，现在就可以收听了。如果你也想收听，但还没有注册“历史就是这样”俱乐部，那么你可以去therestishistory.com注册。非常感谢你，多米尼克。谢谢大家的收听。再见。再见。
Throughout time, celebration has meant giving. So the Romans at Saturnalia handed out all kinds of gifts, The three magi handed out gold, frankincense and myrrh, and the Victorians absolutely loved wrapping things up in paper and then tying it up in string. It's on those are lovely gestures, but I wonder if they're a little bit too extravagant for the typical Christmas morning. So this year, here's my suggestion to our listeners and our viewers. Why not give something a little bit more enlightened?
纵观历史，庆祝意味着给予。罗马人在农神节上分发各种礼物，三位智者分发黄金、乳香和没药，维多利亚时代的人非常喜欢用纸把东西包起来，然后用绳子系好。这些都是可爱的姿态，但我怀疑对于典型的圣诞节早晨来说，它们是否有点太奢侈了。所以今年，这是我对听众和观众的建议。为什么不送一些更有启发性的东西呢？
Why not give the gift of the rest is history club membership? It's the discerning choice for anybody who prefers a Hannibal to a hamper. It's ad-free listening. You get a weekly bonus episode. You get early access to live shows. And you get exclusive deep dive series. Also, on top of that, this year's special gift edition of Restis History Club membership comes with a sensational exclusive t-shirt. It will make you the envy of all your neighbours and all the cool people in your neighbourhood.
为什么不送一份“历史就是这样”俱乐部的会员资格作为礼物呢？对于任何喜欢汉尼拔胜过喜欢礼品篮的人来说，这是一个有眼光的选择。它是无广告收听。你每周会得到一集额外剧集。你可以提前收听现场演出。你还可以获得独家深度系列节目。此外，今年特别版的“历史就是这样”俱乐部会员资格还附赠一件轰动一时的独家T恤。它会让你成为所有邻居和社区里酷人们羡慕的对象。
if such people exist, will admire you and want to spend more time with you. So just head to the rest ishistory.com and click on gifts. That is therestishistory.com and please click on gifts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果这样的人存在的话，他们会钦佩你并想花更多时间和你在一起。所以只需前往therestishistory.com并点击“礼物”。网址是therestishistory.com，请点击“礼物”。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。